Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal, hast du schon mal ein Award bekommen?
Tim, bevor wir ein Grimme Online Award kriegen, kriegt Trump einen Friedensnobelpreis.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 535 vom 14. Oktober 2025.
Ich fühle mich preiswürdig.
Da musst du nur irgendwie ein komplettes Land in Schutt und Asche legen und
sagen, ihr habt jetzt Frieden.
Okay. Und dann sagst du, was ist der zu Preis?
Nee, dann sagst du hier, dann forderst du noch, pardon, was ist das deutsche Wort?
Eine Begnadigung oder Amnestie für irgendwie korrupten Politiker.
Okay.
Und dann hast du eigentlich gute Chancen. Man muss auch sagen.
Der kriegt jetzt noch seinen Friedensnobelpreis?
Ja, der Trump hat sich doch gut gemacht. Guck mal, er hat jetzt,
nein, der hat sich doch gut gemacht.
Der hat jetzt überhaupt nicht irgendwie sexistisch die Preisträgerin beleidigt.
Alles, was sie machen musste, war freundlich ihm ihren Preis widmen,
um das zu verhindern. Also man lernt ja auch langsam, wie man mit ihm umgeht.
Ja.
Die freuen sich doch auch jetzt über den Frieden. Das ist doch super.
Siehst du doch richtig, die werden den am Ende noch selber fordern,
den Friedenswählpreis für Trump.
Aber wir kriegen keinen Grimme Awards, sagst du?
Wir kriegen keinen Grimme Awards. Ne, wir machen Grimme Awards.
Wir machen die Preisträger. Wir dienen die an. Bei uns lernen die Leute, die kennen.
Ja, wie es so läuft im Business. Und dann eigentlich sind wir Trainer.
Wir bringen die online. Who put the online in Grimme Award?
Oh Gott. Wir haben gute Nachrichten zu verkünden.
Nämlich ein Grimme Online Award für die Parlamentsrevue. Für Sabrina Geller,
die ja auch schon zu Gast war.
Und ja, ich kann nur sagen.
Verdient.
Verdient. Und das Ganze auch noch in der Kategorie Informationen. Da passt es gut rein.
Ich habe mir jetzt keine Aufzeichnung angeschaut. ob da noch irgendwelche angemessene
Lobes-Hymnen angestimmt wurden, aber dem würde ich mich auf jeden Fall mal anschließen,
egal was da gesagt wurde.
Wahrscheinlich wurde, also üblicherweise bei so einer Preisverleihung wird gelobt.
Würde mich jetzt wundern, wenn da so eine kritische Würdigung so,
also ich gebe jetzt hier mal ein Feedback, ne?
So wie Kommentare, ja? Webkommentare.
Wie heißt nochmal dieser beknackte Rapper? hat der dich da irgendwann mal bei
so einer Der beknackte Rapper. Der richtig beknackte.
Der mit den Adidas-Schuhen.
Der wirklich richtig beknackte.
Sie sind alle beknackt und die haben alle Adidas-Schuhe an.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Wie heißt der denn? Der dann auch im Apple-Store
irgendwann mal auf den Tisch gegangen ist und geklettert ist und gesagt hat,
man soll Donald Trump wählen.
Ach der.
Ja, ich sag der beknackte Rapper, da hab ich schon eine Baseline.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Jay-Z? Nee. Jeezy hießen die Schuhe Kanye.
Kanye West Der hat sich auch irgendwie so einen komischen Namen gegeben Ach der.
Heißt auch nicht mehr so.
Ich weiß es nicht, ist es mir auch so egal Diese Leute sind einfach so unwichtig
Da verschwinde ich noch nicht mal einen Gedanken da dran Anyway,
bleiben wir beim Grimme Online Award Ach ja.
Haben wir noch einen Ja.
Es ist ja nicht unsere einzige Leistung gewesen Dieses Jahr Die dieses Jahr
gezeigt haben Das darfst du jetzt präsentieren.
Zentrum für politische Schönheit.
Genau. Für AfD-Verbotskampagne haben sie das erhalten. Publikumspreis.
Wollte gerade sagen, das wundert mich. Die Jury haben die Memo nicht bekommen.
Ja, sind sie noch nicht so gut da drin, online da Einfluss zu nehmen.
Gut. Können sich alle an der Wand hängen. Alles super und pipapo.
Wie wird der ausgedruckt? Wie wird der Kribbe online? Und was ausgedruckt?
Ist das nicht ein NFT?
Ist irgendwas mit Acryl.
Der wird ausgedruckt. Ey, also wirklich, please consider the environment before
printing this Grimme Online Award.
Das ist ein bisschen unglaubwürdig, ne?
Dinos, wir haben Besuch.
Ja, die neuen. Also wir stellen jetzt den Grimme Online Preisträger fürs nächste Jahr.
Sehr würdig.
Ja, Thomas und ich sind heute hier, um unseren neuen Podcast vorzustellen.
Wir begrüßen Kalesi, hallo.
Hallo.
Endlich wieder da und auch Thomas und alle, Thomas Lohninger,
Hallo. Ich muss mal vielleicht dazu sagen, hallo. Alle vor Ort.
Ja. Deswegen ist es hier auch so juvial.
Ja, Netzpolitik All Stars.
Ja, physisch. So sieht es aus. Eine Power-Ausgabe von LNP.
Ja.
Power.
Also man könnte fast sagen, also Grimmy Moore.
Naja, also ich weiß nicht, ich brauch kein Award. Ich sag immer,
wenn die Leute mir irgendwie so komische Nominierungs-Mails schreiben,
dann sag ich immer so, trage mich wieder aus.
Sowieso nur Spam.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ich war einmal in so einer Jury und seitdem ist das Thema
Awards für mich gestorben.
Also wenn man mal weiß, wie das da so zugeht, dann hat man irgendwie das, also das ist...
Nein, das ist, also eindeutig hat die Jury ja hier ihre Arbeit gemacht oder
zumindest wurde ihr was ordentliches hin nominiert.
Wir sollten vielleicht einen Logbuch-Netzpolitik-Award für besondere Leistungen
im netzpolitischen Bereich oder so weiter hinaus.
Wir können ja nicht uns selber, also wenn wir ein Award haben wollen,
können wir den nicht selber machen. Das muss schon jemand anders dann. Was?
Wieso? Nicht für uns der Award.
Achso, du meinst diesem alten.
Wir verleihen den einfach anderen Leuten.
Ne, das ist ja eh, also das ist ja der Grund, warum Leute oder Organisationen
Awards vergeben, ist ja, um sich selber mit den Preistickerinnen zu schmücken.
Außer dem Big Brother Award. Ja, wobei, das machen die eigentlich auch, das stimmt.
Ich würde sagen, die schmücken sich auch.
Ja, und mit wem wollen wir uns schmücken? Mit wem könnten wir uns denn?
Gibt's überhaupt, gibt's jemanden, mit dem wir uns schmücken könnten? Sollten? Würden?
Müssten? Weiß ich nicht.
Wahrscheinlich nicht. Also gehen wir keinen Preis raus. Gibt's kein Award. Habt ihr Pech gehabt?
Wenn, dann bräuchten wir so ein Award für, wer quasi die Sendung hier am Kacken hält.
Und das wäre dann so, da könnten wir den Ashton Kutscher und seine Lobbybande auszeichnen.
Die haben uns jetzt über drei Jahre mit der Chatkontrolle beschäftigt,
womit wir beim Thema wären.
Oh Mann, ey. Na gut. Also kein Award. Ja, genau.
Womit wir beim Thema wären. Chat-Kontrolle ist mal wieder in aller Munde. Wie kommt es nur?
Das Ding wäre ja schon längst aus dem Bahnhof. Ist aber nicht so.
Ja, ich würde sagen, ich habe zwar kein Award gekriegt, aber ich habe es mit
der Chat-Kontrolle auf die Seite 1 der Bild-Zeitung geschafft.
Wirklich?
Du warst auf der Seite 1? Nein, zum Glück nicht.
Oder Seite 3.
Du warst Seite 1.
Ich habe mich die ganze Zeit gewundert, wie das Thema in die Bild kam.
Ich wusste nicht, dass du da...
Das ist dir gar nicht aufgefallen, obwohl du mir ein Bild geschickt hast.
Ich gucke immer nur die Hälfte, ich fasse ja nicht an.
So viel muss man geben im netzpolitischen Aktivismus.
Okay. Sag mal, Bild-Zeitung, erklär uns.
Ja, mit der Bild-Zeitung hatte ich nichts zu tun und zum Glück wurde ich auch
nicht zitiert. Das ist glaube ich auch nichts, worauf man Wert legt.
Aber die Chat-Kontrolle war trotzdem Thema, sowohl online als auch in der Papierform.
Bei der Bild-Zeitung. Ich glaube, das war dann der Moment, wo die CDU auch umgekippt
ist, weil sie dem Druck nicht mehr standhalten konnten.
Aber in den letzten jetzt sind es glaube ich fast drei Wochen,
die letzte Woche war ein bisschen verrückt, hat sich irgendwie das Blatt gedreht
um die Chat-Kontrolle und,
ja, das führte dazu, dass Jens Spahn und Rainer Wendt sich gegen die Chat-Kontrolle
ausgesprochen haben. Was?
Rainer Wendt? Aber der ist doch kein echter Polizist.
Eben, deswegen war er natürlich auch gegen, also das ist ja klar,
jetzt haben wir den Beleg, dass das kein echter Polizist ist.
Ja, ich glaube es geht noch weiter, schöne Anekdote, aber das erzähle ich euch
später, was wir noch für Polizistengespräche hatten.
Aber ganz grundsätzlich ist das Thema aufgekommen, weil ein Vorschlag zur Chatkontrolle
mal wieder auf der Agenda im Rat stand.
Und das war diesmal der Vorschlag von der dänischen Ratspräsidentschaft.
Ich glaube, ihr habt das hier auch schon mal kurz erläutert.
Genau, der aber unverändert war. Also die haben doch einfach nur den alten wieder vorgelegt.
Oder? Nee, die haben so Copy-Paste gemacht von, ich würde sagen,
den All-Star-Worst-Case-Vorschlägen.
Ah, okay.
Also die haben einfach gedacht, okay, wir haben uns jetzt dreieinhalb Jahre
nicht geeinigt. Was machen wir?
Wir copy-pasten halt einfach die schlimmsten Vorschläge zusammen und hoffen dann auf Zustimmung.
Das ist eine bewährte Strategie im Rat.
Wir haben innerhalb von 48 Stunden, oder 72 waren es glaube ich dann am Ende,
viel länger ist die Petition nicht online gewesen, über 300.000 Unterschriften
gegen die Chatkontrolle gesammelt.
Wie gesagt, Rainer Wendt war dagegen, der Kinderschutzbund hat sich auch nochmal
dagegen ausgesprochen,
diverse andere Verbände, mittelständische Unternehmen, alle sind eigentlich,
also nach wie vor, ich glaube das ist unverändert, sind gegen das ganze Thema Chatkontrolle.
Und das Ganze gipfelte dann darin, dass erst das Justizministerium,
dann Jens Spahn und dann auch die Bundesregierung zumindest gesagt hat,
sie lehnen eine anlasslose Chatkontrolle ab und sie werden den dänischen Vorschlag nicht annehmen.
Sie zieren sich weiterhin noch ein
bisschen im Hinblick auf eine generelle Positionierung zur Chatkontrolle.
Weißt du, was ich an der Sache so wirklich spannend finde?
Und dieser EU-Gesetzgebungsprozess, die Initiative zur Chatkontrolle kam,
mal gucken wie viele Sätze ich sage, bis du mich unterbrichst,
weil es Quatsch ist, die Initiative kam von der Kommission.
Dann hat das Parlament eine ablehnende Positionierung zu dem Thema gefunden.
Ist immer noch richtig.
Nur eine ablehnende Position gegen das Scannen von interpersoneller Kommunikation,
aber nicht gegen das Gesetz an sich.
Okay, gegen diesen Teil des Gesetzes.
Ja.
Und nun ringt der Rat, also die Mitgliedstaaten,
die Regierungen der Mitgliedstaaten, die zuständigen Ministerinnen der Mitgliedstaaten um ihre Position.
Dort ändert sich am laufenden Band die Ratspräsidentschaft und seit drei Jahren
versuchen die da immer einen neuen Anlauf,
unter Berücksichtigung der wechselnden Mehrheitsverhältnisse in diesem Rat,
weil währenddessen ja die ganze Zeit in Ländern Wahlen stattfinden und sich
manchmal die Regierung ändert, so zum Beispiel in Deutschland,
irgendwie zu einer Einigung zu kommen.
Was ja ein verhältnismäßig...
Langwieriger und in seinem Ende nicht absehbarer Prozess ist.
Und ich fand es jetzt erstaunlich, dass ausgerechnet wir kippen den alten Vorschlag
oder alte Vorschläge ohne nennenswerten Fortschritt oder Änderung,
einfach wieder rein, dass ausgerechnet das nach drei Jahren das Thema irgendwie
auf Bild-Zeitung Seite 1 kriegt.
Nicht irgendwie Kommission oder sonst was oder Parlament stimmt dagegen,
sondern im Prinzip so eine,
und es ging ja noch nicht mal darum, darüber abzustimmen, sondern es ging darum,
das Thema auf die Tagesordnung zu setzen.
Nee, es ging schon darum, also ursprünglich war die Ansage, dass am 14.
Darüber abgestimmt werden soll.
Und dann haben sie sich vorher nochmal getroffen, um zu schauen,
ob das was bringen würde und haben sie gesagt, ah nee, dann lieber doch nicht.
Und vielleicht zu deiner Erörterung muss man nochmal sagen, die Ratspräsidentschaft
müsste nicht dieses Thema an Prio einsetzen.
Sie könnten auch einfach sagen, packen wir nicht an.
Next, thank you next. Das wäre auch noch eine Option.
Genau, das ist jetzt bisher noch nicht passiert, aber es kann auch passieren,
dass so ein Gesetz einfach von der Ratspräsidentschaft nicht angefasst wird.
In den drei Jahren gab es da bestimmt auch mal eine, die es einfach nicht angefasst
hat oder nicht großartig vorangetrieben hat, oder?
Die Polen hatten einen positiv zu bewertenden Vorschlag gemacht,
der dann auch nicht durchgekommen ist, aber dann haben sie es auch nicht weiter angefasst.
Aber ansonsten glaube ich, haben von diesen sechs alle irgendeinen Vorschlag gemacht.
Es gibt ganz oft, dass Gesetze halt dann einfach auf der Agenda verschwinden.
Die Privacy-Verordnung ist ein gutes Beispiel.
Da hätten wir gehofft, dass das kommt, aber keine Ratspräsidentschaft hat es
interessiert. Der digitale Euro wurde auch längere Zeit eher nicht verhandelt.
Da bewegt sich jetzt aber mit Trump im Weißen Haus wieder ganz viel.
Aber der macht dann nicht auch noch mit, ne? Noch nicht, noch nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist so mit Epstein und so Trump würde eher Abstand halten von
einem Gesetz gegen Kindesmissbrauch. Hoffentlich.
Die,
was ich einfach nur tatsächlich als Beobachtung spannend finde,
ist, dass ein derartiger, sich ewig potenziell in die Länge ziehender Prozess
mit irgendwelchen Geschäftsordnungstricks, wo die halt sagen,
wir bringen die Abstimmung aber nur auf die Agenda, wenn sie in unserem Sinne läuft,
weil das wäre ja, man kann ja auch sagen, okay,
meine Güte, du willst etwas zur Abstimmung stellen, dann mach's halt,
ja, aber nutz doch nicht jetzt irgendwie deine Macht der Agenda-Gestaltung, um zu sagen,
ja nee, Moment, ich tue das ja nur auf die Agenda, wenn es in meinem Sinne entschieden wird.
Da kann ich schon verstehen, dass dieser Prozess nicht geeignet ist,
eine politische Anteilnahme zu fördern, die nicht früher oder später darin mündet,
dass die Leute komplett ermüden.
Also ich finde es super gut, dass es dann irgendwie gerade mit so einem komischen,
eigentlich so einem Geschäftstagesordnungs, hast du nicht gesehen,
Hintergrundgeplänkel auf Bild-Zeitung Seite 1 kamen.
Kann man natürlich auch Abzüge in der B-Note geben, weil sie dann die EU blamen,
statt die Bundesregierung und so weiter.
Ja, aber ich glaube, das liegt auch daran, dass in dieses Narrativ,
was jetzt eigentlich mit der Chatkontrolle ist, ein bisschen so eine Urgency
reingebracht wurde in der Erzählung.
Nämlich, wenn das jetzt durch den Rat geht, dann kommt die Chatkontrolle.
Das ist die Erzählung, die aufgemacht wurde.
Was faktisch natürlich nicht stimmt, praktisch aber natürlich der Fall ist,
weil, was kommt nach, nachdem der Rat sich geeinigt hat, Linus?
Sehr gut, sehr schön, freu ich mich.
Aber jetzt, wenn du hier einfach mal so Scherzfragen stellen kannst,
wo du meinst, mich aus dem Konzept zu bringen, erklär mir mal bitte kurz den
Unterschied zwischen praktisch und faktisch.
Den hast du gerade dargestellt.
Nein, ist gemein.
Ich kann dir erklären, was ich damit meinte. Praktisch bedeutet es ja,
dass im Trilog erstmal noch sehr lange verhandelt werden muss.
Und dann könnte man natürlich sagen, okay, diese Panikmache macht überhaupt
gar keinen Sinn, weil die verhandeln doch jetzt bestimmt wieder noch tausend Jahre wie beim AI-Act.
Aber was man da auf der Pfanne haben muss, ist, die Kommission hat eine Position,
die nicht in unserem Sinne ist.
Das Parlament hat eine relativ gute Position mit einem Berichterstatter,
der eine katastrophale Position hat zu dem Thema.
Und wenn wir jetzt noch den Rat hätten mit einer katastrophalen Position,
dann ist relativ klar, was am Ende in dem Text stehen wird, wenn die zu dritt verhandeln.
Katastrophal.
Und man muss auch noch dazu sagen, die Parlamentsposition ist die beste,
die wir haben zu dem Gesetz, aber sie ist immer noch desaströs,
wenn man es neutral betrachtet.
Es gibt auch dazu eine Stellungnahme von den europäischen Datenschutzbehörden,
die dem Gesetz auch weiterhin Verfassungswidrigkeit attestieren. Also das ist nicht gut.
Aber das kommt ja danach. Wir sind ja jetzt erstmal noch im Gesetzgebungsprozess.
Danach kommt dann die...
Man sollte sich schon mit seinen Gesetzen an die Verfassung halten,
wenn man will, dass sie halten.
Aber das ist out of fashion. Okay, Kalisi, ich habe nur kurz beobachtet,
was mich an diesem Prozess etwas aus offener Metaperspektive fasziniert hat.
Wie habt ihr das denn jetzt geschafft, diese Aufmerksamkeit auf das Thema zu bekommen?
Weil es ist ja nicht so, als hätte man nicht vorher über viele Jahre versucht,
Aufmerksamkeit auf dieses Thema zu lenken.
Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Pressemitteilungen wir auf ccc.de inzwischen zu dem Thema haben.
Ja, ich glaube, es sind unterschiedliche Sachen passiert.
Also zum einen gibt es ja noch diese Fight-Chat-Control-Seite,
die von einem dänischen Entwickler gebaut wurde,
der sozusagen, ich sag mal, in anderen Gewässern auch fischen gegangen ist,
als wir das vielleicht sind.
Und ich habe ja schon, ich glaube...
Meinst du, der hat Rainer Wendt und Jens Spahn?
Nee, der nicht. Aber zusammen mit File Chat Control und auch vielfach verlinkt
dem Leitfaden zu, wie schreibt man eigentlich seine Abgeordnete und sein Ministerium an,
haben alle Politiker, ich glaube, in den Fünftausendern E-Mails bekommen zu diesem Thema.
Und die CDU hat so ein kleines Trauma, insbesondere Axel Voss,
wenn sie E-Mails bekommen.
Also ich habe auch schon von einigen gehört, also die Rückmeldungen sind dann teilweise auch, ja,
es ist so ein bisschen so wie, das sind alles Bots, das ist nicht das,
was sie sagen, das haben sie inzwischen in ihrem Wording geändert,
aber es sei nicht repräsentativ, diese 5000 E-Mails, die sie zu dem Thema bekommen haben.
Aber das hat die ganz schön eingeschüchtert und das ist eigentlich auch gut
zu wissen, dass die CDU Angst vor E-Mails haben.
So kriegen wir sie.
Genau, ich habe das schon relativ früh zu aufgerufen.
Ich glaube vor vier Wochen oder so habe ich gesagt, hey, wenn ihr irgendwas
machen wollt, geht zur Abgeordnetenwatch, guckt, welche Abgeordnete für euch
zuständig ist, guckt, welche Ministerinnen interessant sind.
Das haben wir dann irgendwie noch eine Stufe höher weitergetrieben und da noch
einen kleinen Leitfaden zugeschrieben.
Und das hat tatsächlich extrem gut funktioniert.
So gut, dass auch ein Jens Spahn dann unter Druck eingeknickt ist und gesagt
hat, er ist gegen die Chatkontrolle.
Was sehr lustig ist, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es mitbekommen habt,
also die CDU behauptet, sie ist schon immer gegen die Chatkontrolle.
Also sie sind noch nie dafür gewesen.
Das ist äußerst interessant.
Das ist natürlich nicht der Fall.
Und das war es jetzt schon?
Was wir gemacht haben?
Naja, aber was passiert als nächstes?
Was passiert als nächstes? Also wir haben ja erstmal noch, das habe ich noch
gar nicht erzählt und ich glaube
es wurde auch noch irgendwo medial aufgegriffen. Wir haben ja diese...
Bei der Nachbuch Netzpolitik hörten sie es zuerst.
Naja, genau.
Grimme Online-Oboard verdächtigt jetzt, die nächste Ausführung.
Wir haben ja diese über 300.000 Unterschriften gesammelt in der einen Woche
und wir dachten, naja, das Bundesjustizministerium hat sich ja schon positioniert,
aber das BMI, dem muss man glaube ich nochmal erklären. Was da das Problem ist.
Und deswegen wollten wir das dem BMI auch gerne überreichen.
Und dann haben wir da an der Pressestelle angerufen und gesagt,
ja Mensch, wir würden Donnerstag vorbeikommen mittags und würden das überreichen.
Würden sie die Unterschriften denn entgegennehmen? Und dann sagten die,
ja, können sie in den Briefkasten werfen?
Und dann haben wir gesagt, nee, also in den Briefkasten werfen wir das nicht.
Und dann haben wir uns da vom BMI aufgebaut.
Warum habt ihr nicht einfach angedroht, dass ihr die per E-Mail schickt?
Ich habe noch Angst vor Ihnen.
Jede Unterschrift einzeln.
Stimmt, das ist eine gute Idee. Das machen wir vielleicht nächstes Mal.
Ist in Datenschutz technisch vielleicht schwierig.
Dann haben wir uns da so aufgebaut und unsere Fotos gemacht und gewartet.
Und wir dachten eigentlich, okay, es kommt keiner.
So nach einer Stunde, als wir gerade eigentlich im Gehen begriffen waren.
Kam dann ein Referatsleiter und sagte, ja, er würde das jetzt entgegennehmen.
Der hat sich ausgehalten, der musste rauchen.
Nee.
Und der hat dann die Unterschriften auch noch entgegengenommen.
Der Polizist, der da die Demo beaufsicht hat oder einer von den Polizisten sagte,
naja, er würde das eigentlich genauso sehen wie wir.
Ich weiß nicht, ob der Rainer Wenz Einfluss widerschlägt oder ob er das tatsächlich so sieht.
Dann gab es noch eine Aktuelle Stunde im Bundestag zu dem Thema und das nächste,
was jetzt passiert ist, naja, das wird wahrscheinlich im Dezember wieder auf der Agenda stehen.
Also wir machen sozusagen im Rat. Auf der Agenda im Sinne von,
wir würden das gerne auf die Tagesordnung setzen.
Um darüber abzustimmen.
Das heißt, die machen jetzt einfach weiter.
Business as usual. Europäische Bürokratie ist einfach immer weiter.
Es wird wahrscheinlich im Dezember wieder auf der Agenda sein.
Und ich habe es vorhin schon so halb betont, sie lehnen eine anlasslose Chatkontrolle ab.
Das kennen wir schon, das hat Nancy Faeser auch schon mal gesagt.
Eine anlassbezogene Chatkontrolle ist aber in Ordnung. So.
Was gilt als Anlass? Also ist das Verdacht bezogen auf Individuen oder ist dieser
Anlass, was Sie ja auch teilweise drin haben, so diese Plattform ist grundsätzlich geeignet.
Wir haben jetzt festgestellt, dass da besteht eine große Gefahr.
Genau, also das ist das, was die EU-Kommission sagen würde. Die würde sagen,
wir haben ja einen Anlass, wir müssen ja Kindesmissbrauchsmaterial finden.
Die Bundesrepublik Bundesregierung meint, glaube ich, schon,
dass es Anordnungen geben soll, juristische.
Aber die Frage ist natürlich, was das rechtlich und was es technisch heißt.
Und technisch ist es nun mal so, das geht halt nicht. Also wir können halt keine
Chatkontrolle auf Anordnung machen.
Weil es ja auf dem Gerät stattfinden soll und damit die notwendige technische
Voraussetzung sowieso auf jedem Gerät sein muss.
Und dann die technische Umsetzung des nun findet eine Anordnung statt und schaltet dieses Ding.
Also das ist sozusagen das Ding in dieser ganzen Diskussion um das Anlassbezogene,
aber um nochmal die nächsten Schritte durchzugehen.
Also erstmal gibt es einen Antrag sowohl von den Grünen als auch von der Linkspartei
im Bundestag, einen Artikel 13 Antrag, das heißt sozusagen eine nicht bindende
Abstimmung des Bundestages, die sagen kann, die Bundesregierung soll sich so
und so zu diesem Thema positionieren.
So, das ist das Einzige, was der Bundestag in diesem Fall tun kann,
weil am Ende ist das eine Abstimmungssache zwischen den Ministerien.
Also eine nicht bindende Abstimmung der Opposition.
Nee, nee, also des gesamten Bundestags.
Wenn sie mit dem Antrag durchkommen. Genau, aber auf Wunsch der Opposition.
Also da haben wir natürlich riesige Erfolgsaussichten.
Erstens, dass sich da eine Mehrheit durchsetzt und zweitens,
dass sich dann die Regierung daran hält. Damit ist das Thema eigentlich tot.
Genau und was halt jetzt wichtig ist, ist, ich glaube, wir haben so ein bisschen
den Aufmerksamkeitspeak erreicht von diesem Thema leider.
Also da nur als Kommentar, ich dachte ehrlich gesagt, den hätten wir längst hinter uns.
Den Aufmerksamkeitspeaker. Insofern bin ich sehr froh, dass wir nochmal einen
hatten. So Gartner-Hype-Cycle.
Ja und ich glaube, er war auch größer diesmal, um ehrlich zu sein.
Ja, das war überraschend. Also ich muss wirklich sagen, absolut fasziniert und
kann es bis jetzt nicht ganz ergründen, welche Sterne richtig standen,
dass man ausgerechnet in diesen Zeiten, da gab ja auch andere Themen.
Ich glaube aber auch, dass sowohl Signal als auch WhatsApp, als auch Threema,
aber vor allen Dingen WhatsApp was dazu gesagt haben.
Das ist glaube ich für die breitere Masse auch noch ein Faktor.
Aber Artikel 13 wird 23, Entschuldigung, falsches EU-File.
Von den Westen passiert.
Ja, Artikel 23, Abstimmung, schauen wir mal.
Aber was jetzt halt weiter offen bleibt, wird jetzt die Bundesregierung da irgendwas
hinmauscheln mit den Dänen?
Das kann natürlich im Hintergrund noch weiter passieren. Das heißt,
da müssen wir weiter E-Mails schreiben, hätte ich fast gesagt.
Aufmerksam bleiben und Thomas hat vorhin schon gesagt, so richtig Bombe ist
die Parlamentsposition auch nicht und der Berichterstatter für die Chatkontrolle
für das Parlament ist jetzt auch nicht unbedingt uns wohlgesonnen.
Hat der Angst vor E-Mail?
Bestimmt, aber der macht gerne, er hat im Juli, ich habe gerade nochmal nachgeschaut,
eine Schattenberichterstatter-Sitzung einberufen und da waren eigentlich nur
Kinderrechtslobbyistinnen eingeladen und Edri haben sie dann so am Abend vorher
noch eingeladen, weil es eine Presseanfrage dazu gab,
warum keine Vertreterinnen aus dem netzpolitischen Spektrum eingeladen waren.
Also der Berichterstatter ist eigentlich auch eher Kandidat,
er würde jetzt eigentlich ganz gerne zurückrudern.
Also das ist jetzt nicht unbedingt die beste Ausgangsposition, die wir da haben.
Wer ist dieser Berichterstatter?
Das ist Sasa Lejos, den kennen wir auch schon aus diesem lustigen Schaubild.
Ich habe ihn auch damals vorgestellt, als er das allererste Mal war.
Relativ alter, spanischer, konservativer.
Ja, genau.
Okay.
Und was ist eine Schattenberichterstatter? Das ist wieder auch so eine besondere Blüte der Demokratie?
Das ist ja relativ normal. Also es gibt ja meistens einen federführenden Ausschuss
für ein Gesetz und in diesem Fall ist es Liebe und Thomas kann bestimmt die
Abkürzung jetzt aufschlüsseln.
Also im Grunde ist Civil Liberties also das Bürgerrechtskomitee.
So und da sind dann halt für alle...
Also ohne Ehe. Also mit nur einem Ehe.
Hat nichts mit Love oder Liebe zu tun.
Ja, aber wir haben sehr viel mit ihnen zu tun. Wir sind sozusagen in einer festen Beziehung mit Liebe.
Ist ein bisschen toxisch.
Aber wir kommen da nicht mehr raus. Es ist Liebe. Es ist Liebe, genau.
Und da sind halt die ganzen Berichterstatterinnen aus den jeweiligen Fraktionen
und das sind die Schattenberichterstatter.
Okay, und dann diese Anhörung hat vor den Schattenberichterstatterinnen stattgefunden
mit den Vertreterinnen der Kinderrechtsorganisationen. Und Ella.
Genau. Also da muss man vielleicht auch nochmal sagen, weil du gefragt hast,
warum das auch so erfolgreich geworden ist.
Ich finde eine Person, die viel zu wenig Erwähnung findet in unserer ganzen
Diskussion über die Chatkontrolle, ist Ella Jakubowska aus dem E-TRI-Team,
die vor allen Dingen in Brüssel genau auf diesen Veranstaltungen dann nicht
so wie ich, ich habe ja immer die netten Veranstaltungen, ich werde ja immer
eingeladen von Menschen, die gegen die Chat-Kontrolle sind und dann muss ich
über die Chat-Kontrolle sprechen.
Und Ella kommt ohne Einladung.
Und Ella wird dann zu den Events eingeladen, wo so bis an die Zähne bewaffnete,
sehr emotionalisierte Kinderschutz-Lobbyisten sind, die wirklich,
wirklich unangenehme Zeitgenossen sein können.
Und dann muss sie halt unsere Punkte vertreten und da müssen wir ihr wirklich dankbar für sein.
Wahrscheinlich stimme ich voll und ganz zu.
Nicht physisch bewaffnet, aber du meinst einfach, dass sie in der Diskussion
natürlich äußerst unangenehme ...
Das kann ich mir ungefähr vorstellen.
Und die Kinderrechtsorganisation, also das ist schon auch ein hartes Pflaster.
Also das ist nochmal schlimmer als im Urheberrecht. Und dort wird schon wirklich
unter der Gürtellinie geschossen.
Ja, also es ist ein Etappensieg, aber es sieht jetzt nicht unbedingt gut aus.
Und ich glaube eine Sache, die man nicht vergessen darf, ihr habt glaube ich
Protect EU schon mal so peripher angesprochen.
Das ist noch eine ganz tolle neue Strategie, die die Kommission auf die Straße
gebracht hat, nachdem es diese 42 Empfehlungen von der High-Level Working Group on Going Dark gab.
Und es gibt ja jetzt eine Expertengruppe zu Lawful Access to Encrypted Communication.
Und die soll ja jetzt sozusagen rausfinden, wie man das eigentlich machen könnte.
Das heißt, selbst hypothetisch gesehen, selbst wenn wir die Chat-Kontrolle gewinnen
würden und dieses Gesetz aus irgendwelchen Gründen gedroppt wird von der Kommission,
heißt das nicht, dass wir verschüttete Kommunikation gerettet haben,
sondern wir sind dann sozusagen nur im nächsten Level angekommen.
Und ich glaube auch, dass die Bundesregierung sich so zögerlich verhält und
vor allen Dingen das BMI, weil sie ja wissen, dass es diese Expertengruppe gibt.
Und wenn sie jetzt eine zu starke Position einnehmen, um verschützerte Kommunikation
zu schützen, dann würden sie auch dieses Thema komplett blockieren.
Und das wollen sie ja eigentlich nicht.
So, deswegen sage ich immer, wir müssen die Bundesregierung dazu bekommen.
Ja.
Habe ich richtig verstanden, ne?
Das macht die Antifa dann für uns.
Oh nein, jetzt haben wir die wieder,
Nachschrauben.
Jetzt haben wir wieder Kommentare.
Oder die Anti-Anti-Anti-Anti-Anti-Fahrer.
Ja. Nee, aber deswegen müssen wir die Bundesregierung immer wieder dazu bewegen oder,
Das Ziel muss immer wieder sein, ihr müsst Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte Kommunikation
schützen und zwar vollumfänglich und nicht nur ein bisschen und nicht nur ein
bisschen anlassbezogen oder so, sondern wirklich vollumfänglich,
weil dieses Project EU Ding und vor allem diese Expertenkommission ist halt
noch, also wenn du denkst, dass der Prozess um die Chatkontrolle intransparent
war, dann wird das so Intransparenz meisterschaften.
Ich würde gerne noch diskutieren, was jetzt eigentlich als nächstes passieren wird.
Also wir haben jetzt sechs Ratspräsidentschaften, die gescheitert sind daran,
die Chatkontrolle in irgendeiner Form abzustimmen und dafür eine qualifizierte Mehrheit zu finden.
Es ist, wenn jetzt nicht viel sich ändert, kann man ein bisschen optimistisch
sein, dass das auch in Zukunft ähnlich gelagert ist und wir diese Blocking Minority
im Moment halten können im Rat.
Aber die Frage ist halt auch, ist das eigentlich gewinnen oder nicht?
Es gäbe eine Person, die hätte es in der Hand, den Vorschlag zurückzunehmen.
Das wäre Innenkommissar Magnus Brunner, der kommt aus Österreich.
Und in Österreich gibt es ja einen Allparteienkonsens gegen die Chatkontrolle.
Eigentlich wäre es in seinem Interesse hier zu sagen, wir kassieren das ein.
Das ist höchstwahrscheinlich verfassungswidrig, damit ist keinem Kind geholfen.
Und es ist einfach auch etwas, das wahrscheinlich als Gesetz niemals zu einer Lösung kommen wird.
Aber wieso sollten sie das tun? Du hast gerade gesagt, es gibt schon den nächsten
Anlauf, der genommen wird und die Chatkontrolle im jetzigen Status verharren
zu lassen, bindet auch so unheimlich viel Energie.
Da ist einfach dieses riesige Damoklesschwert über unseren Köpfen und man kann
es nie ganz aus den Augen verlieren.
Es wird weiter auch Kräfte binden und die sind in der Zivilgesellschaft nicht
sonderlich gut gesät, sodass auch viele Leute, wenn sie sich auf das konzentrieren,
für andere EU-Prozesse einfach keine Aufmerksamkeit haben.
Also ich befürchte, dass wir relativ lange noch verharren werden in dem Zustand,
auch wenn ich jetzt einer Einigung im Rat wirklich nur noch sehr geringe Chancen
zugestehe, weil meine Lesart,
wieso wir jetzt mehr Aufmerksamkeit auf dem Thema haben,
ist auch, ich habe so dieselben Vibes wie damals bei Upload-Filtern.
Die Expertinnenarbeit in Brüssel bei den Organisationen, die ist über Jahre
gut gemacht worden und jetzt diffundiert das Thema raus.
Jetzt sind Leute, die einfach nur Social Media Influencer sind,
die ihre Kanäle haben, die dieses Thema einfach nur oft genug davon gehört und
so ein bisschen was davon verstanden und dann machen sie es zu ihrem und machen
ein lustiges Video drüber. Aber so kommst du in die Breite.
Also wir können unsere Hoffnung jetzt entweder an einen Österreicher binden,
wo die Wahrscheinlichkeit groß ist, dass er auf einmal unter mysteriösen Umständen
in der Donau schwimmt oder Kokain gehandelt hat. Oder an die YouTuber.
Aber ich glaube, eine Sache, wenn du Uploadfilter sagst, dürfen wir halt auch
nicht aus dem Auge lassen.
Und zwar, die Kinderschutzverbände oder die Kinderschutz-Dobbyisten sind ja nicht blöd.
Und die machen sich natürlich auch Gedanken und es ist jetzt gerade wieder ein
Paper aufgetaucht von der Internetwatch Foundation,
ihr erinnert euch vielleicht das sind die, die immer Zahlen darüber rausgeben wie die,
Distribution von Missbrauchsdarstellungen im Internet sich entwickelt hat wenn
man es kurz fassen will da wird immer mehr.
Weil die Polizei das nicht löscht.
Ja
mit der Statistik gibt es glaube ich auch noch andere Probleme,
da gibt es einen sehr schönen Debunking-Artikel von Netzpolitik.org auch,
aber die schlagen jetzt tatsächlich Upload-Filter vor.
Also die schlagen jetzt vor, okay, wir facken die Verschuldung nicht an,
wir machen einfach einen Upload-Filter in alle Messenger-Dienste und dann alles,
was sozusagen auf der Blacklist ist, kannst du einfach nicht verschicken.
Das ist so die nächste Runde, die wir mit auf dem Tisch haben.
Unterscheidet sich das? Also der Unterschied zur Chatkontrolle wäre,
es wird nur geblockt und nicht der Polizei gemeldet.
Genau, es muss halt keine Ausleitung geben.
Wir verhindern die Strafverfolgung. Wir geben die Gedanken der Strafverfolgung
auf, sondern blocken KI-Stoppschild statt KI-Bulle.
Also genau, Stoppschilder in verschüsselten Messenger-Diensten.
Also Ursula von der Leyen ist bestimmt dabei.
Oh nein, die ist ja auch nicht.
Ich würde gerne einmal noch ganz kurz, weil du ja den Begriff Kinderschutzlobbyisten
und wahrscheinlich absichtlich korrekt gegendert, es gibt nicht die Kinderschutz.
Aber es gibt da glaube ich zwei. Es gibt ja eine Reihe an Kinderschutzorganisationen,
die ein Track Record haben, auch tatsächlich was für Kinderschutz zu tun und
auch dadurch auffallen,
dass sie gegen Chatkontrolle sind.
Und dann gibt es andere Organisationen, teilweise von denen hat noch nie jemand
was gehört. Die wurden neu gegründet mit Venture Capital von Ashton Kutscher.
Die unter dem gleichen,
unter dem gleichen hehren Ziel mitunter natürlich auch eigene ökonomische Interessen pushen.
Also das war ja bei dieser ganzen Ashton Kutscher Sache relativ klar, oder?
Ja, also ich glaube.
Lässt sich das so trennscharf?
Ich glaube, es lässt sich nicht so trennscharf machen. Es gibt halt die einen
und die anderen, sage ich mal so.
Und es gibt zum Beispiel den Deutschen Kinderschutzbund und in Österreich ist es die Möwe,
die teilweise sogar theoretisch auch Mitglied in größeren Kinderschutzbünden
sind, die eigentlich für die internationalen Kinderschutzbünden sind,
die eigentlich theoretisch auch praktisch für die Tätkontrolle sind,
die aber gesagt haben, so nee, wir sehen das anders.
Ich glaube, das Problem mit den Kinderschutzlobbyisten, deswegen betone ich auch immer,
dass es Lobbyisten sind, was die machen, ist halt eine extreme,
Emotionalisierung dieses Themas und das ist glaube ich das, wo wir die letzten
Jahre sehr stark daran gearbeitet haben und was auch immer weiter wichtig ist,
im Hinterkopf zu behalten,
einfach sachlich zu bleiben, zu sagen, wir wollen auch Kinderschutz,
dass diese Maßnahmen, die Sie hier vorschlagen, schützen Kinder nicht und technisch
können wir Ihnen aus einer Fachperspektive
sagen, ist das höchst problematisch und gar nicht auf dieses.
Emotionale Thema einsteigen, weil das ist genau das, worauf die setzen.
Also ihre ganze Strategie ist gelagert auf das Thema total krass zu emotionalisieren.
Das ist genauso, wie das auch mit der Altersverifikation ist.
Eltern sind total damit überfordert, ihren Kindern zu helfen,
im Internet sich zu bewegen und deswegen brauchen wir Altersverifikation.
Also das ist, glaube ich, so der Pfad, den die nehmen.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie lange das her ist. Da war ich mit der Nancy Fäser.
Oh ja, 2022 war das.
Der Vertreterin von Innocence in Danger. Und noch, wer war der noch dabei? Bei Markus Lanz.
Ja.
Ich glaube, die Sendung können wir mal, wenn die noch online ist,
können wir die auf jeden Fall verlinken.
Das war jetzt nicht so schwer, mit dieser Frau zu interagieren,
weil dann natürlich inhaltlich ist das ein bisschen schwach.
Aber man muss halt, also es erfordert eine gewisse Beherrschung,
die mir jetzt auch, die natürlich komplett in meinem Naturell liegt.
Aber wenn man darauf vorbereitet ist, mit diesen Leuten zu interagieren,
dann geht das eigentlich, weil man, also sag mal,
ja, weil da halt inhaltlich ist das eben sehr schwach, emotional sehr stark.
Man hat natürlich immer das Risiko, früh sehr schnell beschimpft zu werden und
mit wirklich unschönen Vorwürfen konfrontiert zu werden.
Wenn man dann nicht auf eine stabile Moderation zählen kann,
dann ist das immer ein Risiko, was Ella dann eben eingeht, wenn sie sich mit
solchen Leuten irgendwie in eine Live-Situation begibt.
Insgesamt sind die aber, ja, also man muss keine Angst haben,
dass sie argumentativ überzeugen.
Nee, aber ich glaube deswegen ist es umso wichtiger, wenn wir jetzt weiter E-Mails
schreiben, zum Beispiel auch an Abgeordnete, immer darauf hinzuweisen,
dass uns der Kinderschutz auch am Herzen liegt und dass das,
was sie vorschlagen, nichts bringt.
Und auch auf dann den Kinderschutzbund und andere Kinderschutzvereine zu verweisen,
die ja auch genau das Gleiche sagen.
Und vor allen Dingen, den Schuh darf man sich halt auch nicht anziehen.
Ich sage immer, als Chaos Computer Club ist ja nicht unsere Kompetenz,
Kinderschutzvorschläge zu machen.
So, das ist nicht unsere Fachkompetenz.
Das heißt, die Antwort, die häufig kommt von Politikern ist ja,
dann müssen sie mir jetzt sagen, was ich stattdessen machen soll.
Und das kann ich als Informatikerin einfach nicht. Ich bin keine Medienpädagogin.
Und das ist halt auch wichtig, da dann halt immer zu sagen, okay, es gibt da.
Wer hat denn jetzt eigentlich die Bringschuld?
Wer hat jetzt hier die Bringschuld? Ich definitiv nicht. Ich kann Ihnen aber
aus technischer Perspektive sein, dass es extrem gefährlich ist, was Sie hier machen.
Ich erinnere, also das ist natürlich auch dieses Kinderthema und Terrorthema.
Es sind ja immer die gleichen beiden, die herangeführt werden.
Da kommt jetzt selten mal jemand und sagt, hier Steuerhinterziehung,
da müssen wir mal was machen. Da denken alle so, nee, lass mal, okay.
Das eignet sich nicht zur Emotionalisierung. Deswegen sind die natürlich so gefährlich.
Das klassische Kinderschutz ist so ein Thema, wo man gerne mal das Kind mit dem Bade ausgießt.
Skisst.
Ja komm, der liegt jetzt auf der Hand.
Insofern würde ich schon sagen, dass wir,
einen ganz guten Track-Record haben, diesen Angriffen entgegenzutreten.
Aber es ist sehr schwierig, weil eben die ein sehr schnelles Argument haben
oder eine sehr schnelle Position haben,
die emotional anschlussfähig ist und wir nur eins haben,
was inhaltlich quasi schwieriger zu vermitteln ist,
und wenig geeignet ist, unmittelbare emotionale Reaktionen hervorzurufen.
Das ist auf jeden Fall ein strategischer Nachteil, den man da immer wieder hat.
Ja und ich glaube, was man aber auch beachten sollte in dieser ganzen Diskussion,
die wirklich wahnsinnig ist um die Chat-Kontrolle, ist,
dass ganz, ganz viele Sachen im Hintergrund, also ich habe das vorhin schon
mit Protect EU gesagt, dass uns das halt irgendwie noch den Nacken brechen muss,
da geht es ja auch um Vorratsdatenspeicherung,
Logbuch-Netzpolitik berichtete und was auch total hinten runterfallen wird und
das ist total in the making in Deutschland, ist Altersverifikation.
Das ist ein großes Thema und das poppt gerade überall auf.
Es poppt überall auf, aber es hat kaum Aufmerksamkeit.
Ja, bis zu spät ist. Also die Gesetze wurden gerade, was zuletzt war Griechenland.
Ja.
Und ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele Länder jetzt schon derartige Dinge verabschiedet
haben. Innerhalb der EU steht das alles auf extrem tünnernen Füßen.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass diese Gesetze beim EuGH halten würden,
wenn sie sich nicht nur auf Plattformen aus dem jeweiligen EU-Land beziehen würden.
Weil da haben wir auch EU-Gesetze, das sogenannte Sitzstaatsprinzip, was dem entgegensteht.
Aber da gibt es einen enormen politischen Willen dahinter. Und die Kommission
hat signalisiert, dass sie da einfach wegschauen wird.
Aber irgendwer kann natürlich klagen, beziehungsweise mich würde es nicht wundern,
wenn wir auch auf EU-Ebene dazu noch Gesetzgebung sehen.
Kalise, erklär nochmal ganz kurz, vielleicht sind ja auch neue Mitglieder in
der Grimme Online Award Jury, die jetzt neu im Thema sind, was das Problem bei
der Altersverifikation ist.
Erstmal denkt man, ja meine Güte, kann man ja eben kurz gucken,
nicht, dass die Kinder hier einfach ins Internet gehen.
Ja genau, vielleicht sollte man gucken, dass die Kinder nicht einfach ins Internet
gehen, so als Erwachsener, so begleitend und man zeigt ihnen,
wie das geht, aber anderes Thema.
Genau, also die Idee von Altersverifikation ist einfach, dass man,
wenn man es übertragen würde, einfach immer überall seinen Personalausweis vorzeigen
muss und sagen muss, okay, ich bin schon über 18 zum Beispiel.
Also egal, ob man Social Media benutzt. Ich glaube, es gibt auch einige,
die das jetzt auf Suchmaschinen ausweiten wollen, weil sie sagen,
wenn man einmal bei Google falsch abbiegt, dann ist man schon beim Enthauptungsvideo.
Also das ist so wirklich die Argumentation.
Das passiert mir auch regelmäßig.
Das ist kein Problem.
Ey. Meine Güte, das ist auch wirklich.
Ne, aber ich glaube, das ist so ein bisschen das Ding. Das heißt,
anonyme und pseudonyme Internetsnutzung wäre dann einfach nicht mehr möglich.
Das ist ein Problem. Und dann ist die Frage, wie setzt man das denn technisch um?
Ich habe gerade so das Beispiel Personalausweis gemacht, das ist Thomas-Tanz-Bereich,
da gehe ich jetzt erstmal nicht weiter drauf ein, aber die grundlegende Problematik ist ja erstmal,
es gibt dann sowas wie Age-Estimation, das heißt das Alter von einer Person
wird geschätzt, das heißt du hältst dein Gesicht irgendwie in die Kamera und dann sagt eine KI,
Linus mit seiner Cap heute, der sieht aus wie zwölf, den lassen wir mal lieber nicht rein.
Das wäre ja sogar noch, das fände ich ja noch scharig.
Schade.
So, und diese KIs sind natürlich auch super diskriminierend,
dann erfassen einige auch einfach biometrische Features, mit Biometrie-Datenbank
sind dann eher andere Personen, die da Erfahrung haben, was da dann alles so rausfällt auf einmal,
also da gibt es ganz, ganz viele Probleme und wenn wir zu dem Personalausweis
sozusagen kommen, dann ist es so, ist halt erstmal die Frage, wie macht man das?
Und wenn man es nur über den Personalausweis machen würde, haben halt alle Personen,
die keine Papiere haben, einfach keinen Zugriff mehr auf soziale Medien.
Ja, ich glaube, Porn ist gar nicht so, dass...
Nein, das ist ja völlig überschätzt.
Das ist natürlich auch ein Problem. Das kann ich total verstehen,
dass das schwierig ist für dich.
Aber ich glaube einfach für insbesondere Menschen auf der Flucht,
die auf bestimmte Social-Media-Sachen angewiesen sind, weil das die einzige
Möglichkeit ist, zu kommunizieren,
ist es tatsächlich ein Riesenproblem. Vielleicht...
Also...
Da bin ich mir jetzt nicht so sicher, ob die nicht vorher ihren Account machen könnten.
Ich denke, das Problem, was du gerade benennst, sehe ich auch.
Ich glaube aber, dass es verhältnismäßig sogar noch klein ist im Vergleich zu
Überidentifikation und überhaupt Menschen die ganze Zeit etablieren,
dass man im Internet andauernd seinen Ausweis zeigen muss.
Naja und ich glaube auch alle Aufdeckungsrecherchen zum Thema Tracking haben
halt auch gezeigt, dass wir jetzt nicht unbedingt Plattformen noch einen weiteren
Datenpunkt geben müssen, wo sie dann nochmal die genaue Identifizierung der
Nutzerin bestätigt bekommen.
Das würden sie mit Sicherheit auch missbrauchen. Also die Idee des Tracking im Internet,
man kann eigentlich sagen, die gesamte Werbeindustrie hat ein Ärgernis in diesem verteilten Internet,
welches sie bei Facebook weniger hat oder bei Instagram oder wo auch immer sie lauern.
Nämlich, dass sie es schwieriger haben, die Personen immer wieder über das Internet,
eindeutig zu identifizieren und zu wissen, das ist die gleiche Person,
die gerade, was weiß ich, Süddeutsche gelesen hat, ist jetzt auf Spiegel Online
und die hat aber gestern noch in dem und dem Idealo nach Kühlschränken gesucht.
Und deswegen knallen wir dir
jetzt hier Kühlschrankwerbung auf Spiegel Online hin oder was auch immer.
Und jede Möglichkeit, Endgeräten und dann den Endgeräten von Personen eine eindeutige Person zuzuordnen,
ist natürlich sehr gerne gesehen von dieser privaten...
Ja, Überwachungsindustrie und das würde dem natürlich einen riesigen Vorschub
leisten, wenn man einfach weiß, es gibt keinen, also überhaupt,
es gibt keinen anonymen Account mehr oder es gibt keine Möglichkeit,
dass du drei Accounts machst, die nicht in einem direkten Zusammenhang stehen,
aufgrund deiner Personalausweisnummer.
Also ich denke nur, dass das das weitaus größere Problem ist im Sinne von betrifft
noch sehr viel mehr Menschen,
als dass Menschen in bestimmten Situationen, die ohnehin nochmal ein sehr viel größeres Problem sind,
keinen Account öffnen können.
Nein, also mein Argument ist einfach nur eines der Anzahl an Betroffenen.
Und ich glaube, was hier die ganze Zeit vergessen wird, deswegen erinnere ich
nur daran, das ist nicht, dass nur Kinder ihren Ausweis zeigen müssen.
Das ist, dass alle ihren Ausweis zeigen müssen.
Ich finde nur, wir kommen ja nachher eh gleich nochmal auf das Thema EIDAS und
das andere Event, wo Tim und ich heute in Berlin waren, aber nochmal zur Altersverifikation.
Man muss da wirklich unterscheiden. Ich glaube, datenschutztechnisch gibt es
Wege, das einigermaßen sauber hinzubekommen, wenn diese Altersverifikation wirklich
Zero-Knowledge, Unlinkable und Unobservable ist.
Nur am Ende hilft dir das halt nichts, weil das ist trotzdem eine sehr wahrscheinlich
staatliche App oder zumindest nach staatlichen Standards zertifizierte App.
Weil am Ende geht es ja um Liability. Du hast ja immer eine Verpflichtung für
die Anbieter, dieses Alter zu checken.
Mit realen Strafandrohungen, weil wenn das nicht der Fall ist,
dann sind wir eben im Status Quo.
Was ja heute passiert mit dem, ich bin über 18, ist ja de facto illegal.
Es wird halt nicht geahndet, was keine spezifischen Bestimmungen dafür gibt.
Aber sogar wenn du so eine Technik hättest, das große Problem ist, dass,
Etwas mit uns tut, wenn wir unsere staatlichen Identitätsdaten verwenden müssen,
um unsere Meinungsfreiheit auf Social Media zu nutzen oder porn zu schauen oder
sonst irgendwas im Internet zu machen.
Das hat einfach einen Chilling-Effekt und der ist durch kein technisches Hilfsmittel
dann widerlegbar oder aufwegbar.
Was glaube ich dann schon irgendwie ein sinnvoller Weg wäre,
aber über das redet man ungern, weil es eben auch die Eltern in die Pflicht
nimmt, dass man wirklich sagt,
das ist jetzt das Gerät eines Kindes und dann ist da über die Eltern eingestellt,
dass das halt die Age Bracket ist und das wird anonym an den Service übermittelt
und dann ist es halt die Verantwortung von YouTube oder von TikTok oder sonst wem,
dementsprechende Inhalte auszuliefern.
Aber dazu müsste man halt eben die Verantwortung verschieben.
Es hätte aber den Vorteil, dass nicht alle Menschen sich ausweisen müssen,
sondern wirklich nur jene Geräte, die von Kindern verwendet würden,
das auch mitkommunizieren für die App.
Aber wer denkt denn an die Kinder?
Naja und ich glaube, eine Frage ist auch, was soll Altersverifikation eigentlich lösen?
Also die einen sagen, dass Kinder keinen Zugriff mehr haben auf Content,
der nicht für sie geeignet ist.
Der nächste sagt, ja, das brauchen wir, weil dann gibt es weniger Hate Speech
und so weiter und so fort.
Aber ich frage mich dann auch immer, wo sind eigentlich die Daten,
die zeigen, dass zum Beispiel, das sind wir wieder bei dieser Klarnamensflicht
im Internet, dass das überhaupt irgendwas bringt gegen die Sachen,
die wir hier bekämpfen wollen.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie bei der Chatkontrolle. Also ich würde immer in Frage
stellen, dass das Ziel, was wir haben, unter dem wir Altersverifikation einführen,
überhaupt erreichbar ist mit Altersverifikationen.
Das ist ein sehr wichtiger Punkt, dass häufig in politischen Diskussionen der
Zweck und die Mittel in einem sehr ungünstigen Verhältnis stehen.
Ich würde gerne nochmal kurz einen Schritt zurück. Du hast gesagt,
eingebracht haben sich Signal.
Okay, Signal hat gesagt, wir gehen aus dem europäischen Markt raus,
wenn es eine Anordnung gibt, dass wir unsere Nutzerinnen...
Potenziell mit einer KI überwachen und automatisiert an die Polizei ausliefern müssen.
Threema hat sich positioniert, glaube ich, immer noch Sitz in der Schweiz.
Neu in der Runde auf jeden Fall WhatsApp. Wie kam es dazu?
Ja, ich glaube, da müssen wir uns bei Markus bedanken oder bei Netzpolitik Org.
Aber ich denke bei Markus.
Moment, da musst du auch sagen, wer ist ja Markus?
Markus Reuter.
Ich glaube, ja.
Der einzige Marke ist bei Netz.
Der einzige Ware.
Oh, oh, oh. Boah, jetzt müssen wir jetzt aufschneiden. Das gefährdet jetzt sein Grimme Online.
Auf jeden Fall hat der einer Sprecherin von Meta entlockt, dass trotz,
sagt sie, trotz gegenteiliger Behauptung untergräbt,
der neueste Vorschlag der Ratspräsidentschaft der EU nach wie vor die Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung
und gefährdet die Privatsphäre, Freiheit und digitale Sicherheit aller.
Also spannend finde ich diesen Satz nach wie vor. Das heißt,
wahrscheinlich war Meta auch vorher schon
der Meinung, dass die Vorschläge Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung untergraben.
Deswegen spannend, dass sie sich jetzt erst positionieren.
Oder er hat eine super Suggestivfrage und hat einfach nur Ja gesagt.
Und ich glaube, eine Sache möchte ich zum Abschluss noch mal sagen,
weil das auch an einigen Stellen immer wieder aufkam.
Also das sind dann die Menschen, die sagen, wieso? Ich betreibe dann einfach
meinen eigenen Messenger und dann habe ich gar kein Problem mit Chatkontrolle.
Ich verstehe, wo diese Personen herkommen, aber ich glaube, das Ziel ist ja
immer, vertrauliche Kommunikation Genau, vertrauliche und verschlüsselte Kommunikation für die breite,
Bevölkerung anzubieten und nicht nur für die Handvoll Menschen,
die die Skills haben, alternative Infrastruktur zu betreiben.
Absolut.
Ja, übrigens möchte ich mal eine vorsichtige Prognose über die Zukunft wagen.
Früher oder später werden die mit diesen Forderungen nicht mehr an diejenigen
gehen, die Apps oder Kommunikationsdienste bereitstellen, sondern an diejenigen, die Geräte herstellen.
Ja, also definitiv und ich glaube, wir werden das Thema auch auf einer ganz
anderen Ebene diskutieren, wenn wir eine Zunahme an AI-Agents beobachten werden,
weil ich glaube, das wird die gefühlte Einstellung von einigen Personen zu diesem
Thema auch nochmal grundlegend verändern.
Nach diesem kurzen Detour zurück, würde ich sagen, wir schließen an Age Verification an.
Für Age Verification braucht man Ausweis.
Und Tim und Thomas waren heute bei, wie heißt die? Sprint.
Sprung Innovation.
Wie viele Innovationssprünge habt ihr heute gemacht?
Oder bist du wieder mit dem Fahrstuhl nach oben?
Das ist ja eigentlich mein Primärsport, Innovationssprünge. Das mache ich ja jeden Morgen.
Ja? Wie sehen die aus?
Kannst du das mal vormachen? Gibt es ein Video zu? Oder hast du so ein Ding,
wo man drauf hüpfen kann?
Das ist geheim.
Das findet alles im Geheimen statt. Da muss meine Privatsphäre jetzt respektiert werden.
Du meinst so einen Innovationsquantensprung machst du da morgens, ne?
Genau, auch ungefähr so weit, wie so ein Quant dann so springt.
Ja, also wir waren heute bei der Agentur für Sprunginnovation.
Rafael Laguna de la Vera steht dem ganzen Projekt ja vor.
Und die haben halt jetzt im Rahmen dieser ganzen Unterstützung der Softwareentwicklung
für die Umsetzung des EIDAS-Prozesses,
also dieser EU-Digital-Wallet, um halt seine Identität im Internet nachweisen
zu können, auf Apps und im Internet.
Haben sie ja diesen Prozess gestartet, wo mehrere Projekte, Firmen,
Entwicklungsgruppen Fördergelder erhalten für einen bestimmten Zeitraum,
um dann in so einem freien, offenen Wettbewerb weiterzugeben.
Und reale Apps zu entwickeln und dabei auch diesen gesamten Protokollprozess,
der damit verbunden ist und die ganzen Backend-Systeme und so weiter auch unter
realen Bedingungen zu testen und dabei auch so ein bisschen in so einem Feature-Wettbewerb zu stehen.
Das ist jetzt nicht im eigentlichen Sinne so ein richtiger Wettbewerb und am
Ende gibt es dann so den Gewinner und das ist dann so die eine App,
die es überleben wird, sondern es ist eigentlich ein bisschen obskurer.
Es war irgendwie mehr oder weniger klar, dass keiner von denen am Ende in irgendeiner
Form so ein richtiger Gewinner ist.
Die haben heute auch so lustige Scheinpreise bekommen.
Ja, das war ein bisschen.
Bisschen cringe, aber egal, was man halt im Prinzip auf dem Weg gewinnen konnte, war eine fortgesetzte,
Förderung dieses Development Und diese Unternehmen und Gruppen machen halt in
der Regel auch alle irgendwie noch einen ähnlichen Kram und andere Dienstleistungen in diesem Bereich.
Also da leben die jetzt nicht primär davon, aber es wird halt quasi gemacht.
Und die mussten das halt alles Open Source entwickeln.
Und insofern war das schon ganz interessant.
Und jetzt macht halt die Sprint dazu dann immer so Veranstaltungen,
wo dann immer diese ganze Arbeit immer nach bestimmten Zeiträumen präsentiert
wird und das war halt heute wieder so eine,
das nennt sich dann Funke und dementsprechend war der Tag halt gefüllt mit den
üblichen epischen Ansprachen und dann mit so Vorstellungen.
Wobei das war irgendwie ein bisschen weird, fand ich.
Also es war so ein größerer Mismatch zwischen Content und Publikum.
Geht dir das auch so? Ich hatte so den Eindruck, die Präsentationen,
die waren so super technisch und super drin und sicherlich gibt es auch einige Experten.
Ich hatte bloß nicht so den Eindruck, dass irgendwie alle Leute mit allen Abkürzungen
so ohne weiteres was anfangen konnten oder sehe ich das falsch?
Also Zielgruppe von dieser Competition, die die Funke ja war,
das war ein Wettbewerb, um Prototypen zu erstellen, das war schon sehr technisch.
Es waren auch die klassischen KMUs aus Deutschland, Niederlande,
Schweiz, die den Fundatrack gewonnen haben.
Beim Nicht-Fundatrack waren es eher viel größere Unternehmen,
die hier sozusagen einfach nur um dabei zu sein da waren. Und all diese Teams, ja das sind Nerds.
Also die können natürlich dann, wenn sie ein Mikrofon bekommen,
wollen sie auch ihre Technik herzeigen, weil darauf sind sie stolz.
Und soweit ich das jetzt Ganze verstanden habe, und das wurde auch in der Zweiteilung
der Veranstaltung relativ klar,
die Sprint ist diese Agentur, die ja auch mit einem eigenen Gesetz in Deutschland
begründet ist und einfach ganz andere Regeln hat, nicht unter den typischen Beamtenstaat fällt.
Und der Funke war dieser Wettbewerb, der jetzt eineinhalb Jahre lang grob gelaufen
ist, in dem diese Prototypen entstanden wurden.
Und das Disclaimer, wo ich ja auch in der Jury war und mit entschieden habe
über die drei Phasen, in denen wir da jeweils im Funded und Non-Funded Track
von sechs auf vier auf, glaube ich jetzt waren es am Ende,
drei Teams runtergegangen sind.
Und nur wenn du in die nächste Runde kommst, bekommst du auch Geld im Funded-Track.
Und was die jetzt aber entwickelt haben, sind einfach Open-Source-Prototypen,
um einerseits Technologie zu entwickeln und zu schauen, was geht.
Diese Tests dürfte die Sprint und über die Band eigentlich auch die deutsche
Bundesregierung auf EU-Ebene sehr clever verwendet haben, als so als Reality-Checking
gegenüber der EU-Kommission und anderen Mitgliedstaaten.
Also hier haben wir immer noch Probleme und das funktioniert in der Praxis nicht.
Also das war eigentlich auch ein Lobbying-Hebel für die Bundesregierung,
um auf den EU-Prozess Einfluss zu nehmen.
Und jetzt sind wir im Oktober 2025 und im Dezember 2026 beginnt ja die Verpflichtung,
mindestens eine Wallet anzubieten als Mitgliedstaat.
Und das Interessante ist, der Hando war der jetzt gerade passiert.
Also das ist auch was, das ich von einigen Teams gehört habe,
dass die Technik, mit der jetzt weitergearbeitet wird, die kommt gar nicht so
primär von den Prototypen.
Die ist davon inspiriert, da werden einzelne Komponenten genommen,
aber jetzt ist halt die Hoheit auch wirklich beim Start da eine offizielle Wallet zu erstellen.
Durchführen wird das auch wieder die Sprint. Von dem, was man durch die Blume hört,
wird der Teil jetzt auch nochmal viel mehr Geld und Steuergeld kosten als der
vorherige, weil sie jetzt natürlich auch das ganze Ökosystem aufbauen und die
Plattformen, über die das Onboarding passiert und so.
Aber ich will sowieso, es würde mich sehr interessieren, wie viel Geld da insgesamt
auch schon mal ausgegeben wurde seit 2021 in Deutschland, aber auch in anderen
Mitgliedstaaten für das ganze Ding.
Und die Anforderung, die man jetzt auch irgendwie hört, jetzt wo die Deadline
immer näher rückt, eine Feature-komplette, interoperable Wallet wird es nie und nimmer geben.
Was man hoffen kann, ist, dass
gewisse Kernfunktionalitäten umgesetzt sind und ich würde mal so tippen,
dass ein gutes Resultat ist, wenn wir so die Hälfte oder acht Mitgliedstaaten haben,
die die Deadline halten und eine Wallet anbieten können.
Und die meisten Mitgliedstaaten werden
das verschlafen und einfach nicht rechtzeitig fertig sein mit etwas.
Und man darf auch nicht vergessen, dadurch, dass Deutschland ja keine weit verbreitete
und weit genutzte E-ID hat, hat man auch mehr Freiheit und mehr Lust auf dieses Projekt.
Also der deutsche Digitalminister redet irgendwie relativ offensiv über die Wallet.
Das findest du in kaum einem anderen Mitgliedsstaat. Und die haben eher eine
Beharrlichkeit und Fahrtabhängigkeit.
Das was wir jetzt haben ist ja gut genug, lass uns da einfach ein bisschen was
dranflanschen und dann geben wir den IE, das Stempel drauf.
Deutschland sind die einzigen, die hier so richtig enthusiastisch auch dieses
EU-Gesetz ernst nehmen.
Und in Punkten freut mich das auch, weil das bei manchen Datenschutz- und auch
Datensicherheitsthemen ist halt auch der Anspruch in Deutschland ein höherer
als in anderen Mitgliedstaaten.
Ja, trotzdem frage ich mich immer noch so ein bisschen...
Dieses Bild, was dort gezeichnet wird.
Also es wird immer davon gesprochen, ja, wir machen ja nicht nur eine App,
wir machen ja hier ein Ökosystem und so.
Und wir hoffen ja, dass es dann ganz viele Teilnehmer gibt, weil es sind ja
auch so viele Apps entwickelt worden.
Und ich frage mich halt, okay, also es gibt dann eine offizielle App,
mit der ich irgendwie meinen Ausweis präsentieren kann. Machen wir uns nichts vor.
Die Zahl der Ausweise, die man darin dann präsentieren kann,
die wird dann erstmal sehr überschaubar sein, ja, wird vielleicht anwachsen,
aber es ist jetzt sozusagen nicht so, dass alle da so einen richtigen Nutzungsstau
haben, den sie loslassen.
Nur weil du deine britische Staatsbürgerschaft nicht abgegeben hast,
also aber wie viele Ausweise glaubst du denn, braucht man?
Naja, ich meine auf jeden Fall halt den Personalausweis musst du da erstmal reinschmeißen.
Das ist auch so ein bisschen der Schlüssel, um überhaupt irgendwie alles andere zum Laufen zu bekommen.
Dann ist der Klassiker natürlich so Führerschein.
Also das ist dann so dieses Nutzungsmodell mit, ich will jetzt hier einen Mietwagen
mieten und will schon mal dem Mietwagenunternehmen alle meine Daten liefern,
damit ich da nicht eine Stunde noch am Counter stehen muss.
Das habe ich trotzdem schon mal gemacht.
Was hast du schon mal gemacht?
Alles machen. Würde ich mir sparen. Ich würde einfach sagen.
Es ist auf jeden Fall so eine Vision, die dort auch geäußert wurde.
Und dann gibt es natürlich so gegenüber Krankenversicherungen und so weiter.
Es ist halt sehr oft schon eigentlich im Wesentlichen dieses Perso-Zeigen.
Und dahinter ist ja der Haupt... Also diejenigen, die darunter meist leiden, sind die Banken.
Die ihre Online-Konten nicht mehr so gut... Das ist die...
Und der Prozess, jetzt musst du mit einem polnischen Callcenter-Mitarbeiter
einen Videocall machen, ach scheiße, schon keinen Bock mehr.
Und das ist bei denen die höchste Abbruchquote für Kontoeröffnung.
Ich hätte sonst noch viel mehr Konten und da könnte ich noch viel mehr unterschiedliche
Zwei-Faktor-Apps haben und mich noch länger damit beschäftigen,
Kontostand abzufragen.
Lustiger Kink.
Ja, wobei letztlich, ich meine auch die Ausweis-App, die es heute schon gibt,
macht theoretisch jetzt auch nicht so sehr viel anderes.
Genau, aber da haben wir auf jeden Fall einen Unterschied zwischen theoretisch,
praktisch und faktisch.
Naja, ich wollte aber jetzt noch auf was anderes hinaus, also diese Vision mit
lustiges, breit gestreutes Ökosystem,
Mir will einfach nicht so richtig
im Kopf, warum überhaupt mehr als eine einzige App, um sowas zu machen,
überhaupt irgendeine Rolle spielen muss oder warum es überhaupt nennenswert
mehr als diese Ausweis-App, die es ohnehin schon gibt, gebraucht hätte.
Zumindest solange es sich alles um den Personalausweis dreht.
Und da es ja jetzt auch eine offizielle geben wird, die dann auch heute präsentiert wurde.
Gibt es eigentlich relativ wenig Incentive für irgendeinen anderen Anbieter. Jetzt,
diese Wallet-App bereitzustellen. Also ich meine, man kann damit kein Geld verdienen.
Also nicht mit dem Zeigen eines Ausweises kannst du kein Geld verdienen.
Schon gar nicht, wenn es halt eine offizielle, kostenlose App vom Staat gibt.
Also was sollte dann der Grund sein, so eine App zu machen?
Bezahlen tut dich auch keiner dafür, dass du die online stellst.
Ja, was bleibt denn dann noch übrig? Dann kannst du halt noch ein bisschen in
Certification machen, aber warum sollte ich jetzt irgendwie,
Werbebanner in meiner Ausweis-Nachweis-Wallet haben wollen oder vermittelt mir
die dann noch andere Dienste und Kredite?
Und mir fehlt da so ein bisschen die Vorstellung für irgendein Business-Modell,
was irgendwas tragen kann.
Also in dem Punkt ist die EU-Verordnung relativ agnostisch und hat vieles den
Mitgliedstaaten überlassen.
Also es gibt keine Antwort auf die Frage, was ist das Geschäftsmodell der Wallet.
Da gab es in Deutschland auch einen relativ langen Konsultationsprozess,
wo am Ende nichts rausgekommen ist.
Es gibt die Verpflichtung, mindestens eine Wallet anzubieten als Staat.
Und Länder wie Deutschland oder Frankreich werden sowas natürlich selber machen.
Andere Länder, die vielleicht kleiner sind, würden da die bestehenden Anbieter verwenden.
Wir wissen zum Beispiel, dass Google sehr bemüht darin ist, seine Wallet auch
als offizielle European Digital Identity Wallet zertifizieren zu lassen.
Und es ist davon auszugehen, dass es ein paar große Player geben wird,
die diese Rolle einnehmen.
Und das Wichtige ist aber sozusagen als User wirst du wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
als eine Wallet haben wollen.
Außer du bist zum Beispiel in zwei Ländern unterwegs. Wenn du in Deutschland
wohnst, aber in Dänemark arbeitest, dann kann es dir schon mal passieren,
dass du vielleicht beide Apps hast.
Die Wallet kannst du auch verwenden, ohne dass dein Personalausweis drinnen ist.
Wenn du zum Beispiel jetzt irgendwelche anderen Ausweise von der Uni in einem
anderen Land oder sowas.
Da gibt es gewisse Edge Cases.
Aber die eigentlich spannende Frage ist dann eben so das Ausweisen gegenüber
den Reliant Parties. Dass das wirklich grenzüberschreitend funktioniert.
Und du dann an der Stelle wirklich die vollen 450 Millionen des europäischen
Binnenmarktes in diese Standardschlacht werfen kannst.
Das ist ja so auch ein bisschen die Hoffnung der Kommission.
Kurze Erklärung, also relying parties in diesem Technik-Sprech von EU-Ideals.
Also quasi das Unternehmen oder die Organisation, dem gegenüber ich mich jetzt ausweise.
Also die sozusagen sich darauf verlässt, jetzt von der Wallet das bestätigt
zu bekommen, dass ich ich bin.
Das ist damit jetzt gemeint. Also meine Krankenversicherung,
das Mietwagenunternehmen, was auch immer.
Ja genau und wenn diese Interoperabilität aber dann auch garantiert sein soll,
dann würde ja sogar auch eine einzige App in ganz Europa im Prinzip ausreichen.
Und naja persönlich denke ich halt auch, wenn man es weiterdenkt,
Sollte es halt auch einfach so einen Standard geben, der dann auch quasi von
den Betriebssystemen implementiert werden kann, gerade weil es da halt kein Geld zu verdienen gibt.
Also in meinen Augen ist das halt eine Systemfunktion.
Entsprechend hat doch auch Google da in diesen Wettbewerb damals was eingereicht.
Korrekt. Google war, das war ja auch glaube ich schon bevor ich da mein NDE
unterschrieben habe, in diesem Podcast meine verkündete kritische Haltung gegenüber Google.
Google war dann aber dabei und Google ist aber nicht in die letzte Runde gekommen.
Hügel hat aber seine Wallet inzwischen unter einer Apache-Lizenz veröffentlicht
und ist da auch Teil von der Open Wallet Foundation und definitiv auch in dieser Diskussion beteiligt.
Also die haben ein Interesse daran, Apple hat das nicht.
Das Ganze ist ja auch ein EU-Gesetz und Apple ist nicht sonderlich gut auf die
EU zu sprechen an der Stelle.
Ob das jetzt am Ende im Betriebssystem landet oder nicht, ganz ehrlich,
da bin ich auch agnostisch, das ist mir am Ende egal.
Ich will schon die Wahl haben zwischen den Wallets, die mir angeboten werden.
Vielleicht ist die Wallet meine Staate scheiße und dann hätte ich gerne vielleicht
eine freie Software-Wallet.
Es gibt auch da Projekte, die wirklich das versuchen, datenschutzfreundliches
freie Software aufzuziehen.
Und ich hoffe, dass auch dieses Ökosystem, das es hier geschaffen ist,
den Leuten Wahlfreiheit bietet.
Man muss aber auch noch erwähnen, es gibt einen Hebel, den das Gesetz vorsieht,
dass du halt deinen Pass, deine Identität aus Staat X, der Staat darf sagen,
welche Wallets er unterstützt und welche nicht.
Also ein ungarischer Pass könnte zum Beispiel dazu führen, dass die ungarische
Regierung sagt, wir haben hier diese eine Wallet und das ist die einzige,
die du verwenden kannst.
Mhm.
Ja, also hast du auf jeden Fall einen Punkt.
Also ich habe auch nicht gesagt, dass es unmöglich sein soll,
was anderes zu machen. Ich sehe halt nur kein Businessmodell.
Das gibt es in meiner Sicht.
Also es müsste irgendein idealistischer Motivationsgrund sein oder eben,
ja okay, das Betriebssystem kann es dann auch halt selber machen und dafür muss
es halt die notwendigen Standards geben.
Aber ich glaube, das, was mich bei dem Thema am meisten eigentlich bewegt hat,
war jetzt nicht ein Ausweis gegenüber dem Staat oder auch die Banken.
Ja klar, wenn ein Unternehmen eine rechtliche Verpflichtung hat,
mich zu identifizieren, there needs to be some way to do so.
Das viel kritischere, finde ich, sind die nicht gesetzlich vorgeschriebenen Anwendungsfälle.
Und über die wird ja auch diskutiert, sei das jetzt im Gesundheitsbereich,
sei das beim Einchecken in ein Hotel, beim Abschließen einer Versicherung,
bei Flugverkehr, Boarding Passes,
aber eben auch bei allem, was Social Media ist, Stichwort Altersverifikation.
Und da mache ich mir die größeren Sorgen,
dass eindeutige Identifikatoren, also Seriennummer für Menschen,
proliferieren, dass das Ganze ein Instrument für Tracking und Profiling wird,
auch welche Perspektive der Staat hier drauf hat.
Also ist das System observable? Kann ich konkretes Nutzungsverhalten beobachten darüber?
Da gibt es eine Reihe von Safeguards, die haben wir in der Vergangenheit ja
eh auch schon durchdekliniert.
Da gibt es auch zwei Kongos Talks, die wir verlinken können von mir.
Was wir heute aber auch vorgestellt haben bei der Konferenz ist ein neues Projekt,
an dem wir jetzt gerade bauen.
Es nennt sich Who Identifies Me. Und das ist der Versuch, wirklich dieses Ökosystem
im Blick zu behalten und da eine Transparenz herzustellen, sodass man wirklich
ein komplettes Datenset hat darüber,
welche Reliant Parties, also welche staatlichen Stellen oder Firmen verlangen
jetzt welche Informationen zu welchem Zweck.
Um dann wirklich eine datengetriebene Analyse machen zu können,
auch Fälle früh zu finden, wo jemand Overasking betreibt, also mehr fragt,
als eigentlich notwendig wäre.
Oder wenn irgendwelche unüblichen Kombinationen kommen, wieso verlangt diese
Versicherung hier auf einmal Gesundheitsdaten?
Vielleicht auch Institutionen, die besonders kritisch sind, Stichwort Migrations-
und Fremdenwesen, welche Daten werden dort angefragt von den Leuten?
Dass wir einfach diese Use Cases als Zivilgesellschaft im Blick halten können.
Das ist das Ziel von dem Projekt und Webseite ist whoidentifies.me.
Da findet man auch ein viel detaillierteres Konzept zu all dem und bald auch
noch mehr Informationen.
Ende des Jahres wird das Ganze als Prototyp veröffentlicht und dann Ende 26,
also wenn IEI das wirklich live geht, wird es einen Piloten mit echt Daten geben
von den Staaten, die halt bis dahin das EIDAS-System umgesetzt haben.
Gibt es denn überhaupt Einschränkungen dahingehend, wer eine Relying Party sein darf?
Also könnte ich das jetzt machen? Könnte ich sagen, hier, Meta-Ebene,
muss ich jetzt mal wissen, wer du bist hier?
Kannst du machen. Es ist eine komplett freie Registrierung, also jede öffentliche
oder privatwirtschaftliche Stelle,
die die Wallet verwenden will, muss sich registrieren und dort eben angeben,
zu welchem Zweck und welche Daten wirst du abfragen und noch ein paar Dinge.
Und dann kriegst du die notwendigen Zertifikate, um mit der Wallet zu interagieren.
Also könnte ich jetzt hier für jeden, der einen Kommentar zur Sendung schreibt,
erstmal Personalausweis reinholen und mein Argument ist, damit muss ich hier
irgendwie Hassrede im Internet verhindern.
Das geht nämlich nur, wenn ich die Anonymität aufhebe. Ihr wisst ja, das böse Internet.
Theoretisch wäre das denkbar und das ist eines der Grundübel,
dass du eben die Identifizierung nicht nur aufgrund einer rechtlichen Verpflichtung
einfordern darfst, sondern du kannst sie auch aufgrund deiner AGBs,
von dem was du dir ausgedacht hast, einfordern.
Und hier kommt noch was zum Schlagen, das haben wir heute auch diskutiert.
Die Kommission hat es wirklich verkackt, dass wir ein Recht auf Pseudonymität bekommen.
Das steht im Gesetz, aber das haben sie über die technische Ausgestaltung fast ausgehebelt.
Und das heißt, die Wallet kann nicht unterscheiden, ob eine Bank dich gerade
nach deinem Namen fragt oder Facebook unterscheidet.
Und das ist natürlich brandgefährlich, aber da haben wir in dem Sanatisierungsprozess
auch mehrmals laut darauf hingewiesen, aber die Kommission hat sich hier wirklich dafür entschieden,
dass die Wallet nicht dem Use Case entsprechend auch gewisse Safeguards anbietet für den User.
Und das ist aus meiner Sicht auch verordnungswidrig, aber so ist es jetzt mal
in den Implementing Acts.
Deutschland und ein paar andere Mitgliedsländer, wie zum Beispiel die Niederlande,
wollen davon abweichen, wollen mehr tun.
Aber im grenzüberschreitenden Fall werden diese nationalen Add-ons,
die aber eigentlich nur ein Bärminimum etablieren werden, sind halt dann nicht
genug, um das Ökosystem als Ganzes sicher zu halten.
Wir versuchen da natürlich ein Maximum auch abzubilden, um diese Unterschiede
auch herauszuarbeiten mit dem Projekt.
Aber ja, also das ist halt wie so oft in Europa, United in Diversity,
das heißt gerade drüben.
Und es ist nicht so, dass der einheitliche Standard wirklich Klarheit schafft.
Und ich glaube, das ist auch ein ganz interessantes Ding bei der Kommission.
Es gibt ja jetzt auch diese Mini-Wallet, die sie rausgebracht haben und all
diese Sachen, die du gerade angesprochen hast, werden da halt auch nicht wirklich berücksichtigt.
Das steht dann zwar in der GitHub-Spezifikation, dass sie das schon machen wollen,
aber in der technischen Implementation sieht man es dann tatsächlich nicht.
Halte ich auch für ein sehr komisches Projekt, dass Sie das jetzt so aus der
Hüfte geschossen nochmal irgendwie zu dem Thema machen.
Vielleicht müssen wir kurz sagen.
Was das ist.
Also wir hatten ja vorhin schon das Thema Altersverifikation und wir wissen
jetzt, die Wallet kommt, aber sie ist eigentlich noch nicht fertig und die EU-Kommission
hat gesagt, naja, wäre ja gut, wenn wir schon mal eine abgespeckte Form zur
Verfügung stellen könnten, die wenigstens Altersverifikation macht.
Und das ist diese Mini-Wallet und das kann man sich auch angucken,
können wir ja vielleicht in den Show Notes verlinken, ist ein GitHub-Repo,
wo sie halt dieses Beispielprojekt schon mal gemacht haben.
Es ist ein Prototyp, glaube ich, es wird jetzt glaube ich schon getestet im Background.
Es gibt acht Länder, die in dem Pilot drinnen sind, Deutschland ist eins davon
und das soll dann halt auch ein europäischer Weg für Altersverifikation sein.
So und das Letzte, was ich noch erwähnen will, ist nur eine offene Bildungsressource,
die wir gerade veröffentlicht haben und zwar dieses ganze Thema Digital Identity
ist ja bei weitem nicht auf Europa beschwenkt.
Im Gegenteil, wenn man mal in Länder des globalen Südens schaut,
sieht man, dass dort die Digital Identity Systeme viel mehr Verbreitung haben,
gerade eben auch in Ländern, die in dem Entwicklungshilfekontext oft diskutiert werden.
Und das hat einen Grund, nämlich dass Institutionen wie die Weltbank oder die
Gates Foundation hier massiv auch finanzieren,
dass solche digitalen Identitätssysteme oder wie sie es gerne nennen Digital
Public Infrastructures ausgerollt werden.
Und ganz oft sind Menschenrechte und Datenschutz dort eher so ein nachträglicher Gedanke.
Da gibt es auch Bewegungen, um daran was zu ändern. Wir haben da gerade ein
E-Learning veröffentlicht, wo wir so all die Learnings aus EIDAS,
all die technischen Datenschutzdinger mal einfach verständlich zusammentragen
für eine auch nicht technische Zielgruppe.
Und auch das verlinken wir, weil das ist frei lizenzierte Bildungsmaterialien
und ich konnte vor zwei Wochen in Uganda in dem Training auch mal einen kleinen
Reality-Check machen, ob das Ganze auch ankommt bei den Leuten und ja, hat sehr gut,
hat unheimlich viel Spaß gemacht und es war ganz schön dann irgendwie so mit
den dortigen Aktivisten auch mal diese ganzen Überwachungsthemen zu diskutieren
Und gerade in einem Land wie Uganda,
wo Rechtsstaatlichkeit nicht so gegeben ist,
hat das trotzdem sehr verfangen und war den Leuten auch ein Anliegen.
Hast du noch was zu sagen zu dem Event heute, Tim?
In welcher Hinsicht meinst du das?
Ja, weil ich sonst weitergehen würde zum nächsten Thema.
Achso. Ja.
Du meinst vielleicht so allgemeine Betrachtung? Also ich finde einfach nach
wie vor die Atmosphäre da sehr unbeamtig.
So wie ein guter Style, der da irgendwie herrscht. Das kann man auch mal betonen.
Also es ist einfach, man hat nicht so das Gefühl, in so einem Behörden-Event zu sein.
Es ist irgendwie gut moderiert und irgendwie fluffig organisiert und entspannt.
Also es ist halt irgendwie nicht so etepetete irgendwie.
Das finde ich eigentlich ganz gut.
Und man kommt auch tatsächlich mit interessanten Leuten da ins Gespräch.
Also ich hatte da ein paar, einige Gespräche, die eher so ein bisschen so neben
dem Thema waren. Einfach interessante Leute da.
Und das kann ich nur begrüßen. Und Hörer der Mitte eben im Übrigen auch. Grüße.
Ja.
Das war ganz lustig, weil der hat zuerst mich erkannt und dann habe ich gesagt,
ich will so Tim treffen, der steht da drüben.
Lustig. Gut, dann gehen wir weiter zu einem weiteren europäischen Thema und
zwar einem, das mir gerade sehr viel Kopfzerbrechen bereitet.
Ich hoffe, dass wir in Zukunft noch mehr darüber reden werden,
weil das hat viel zu wenig Aufmerksamkeit bekommen.
Und zwar geht es um den Omnibus. Linus, was ist ein Omnibus?
Ja, irgendwie ein Bus, wo jeder rein kann und ich deswegen nicht reingehe.
Und oben Lautsprecher draufstehen.
Das ist ja kein Omnibus, da kommt ja nicht jeder rein, sonst wird die Polizei
ja nicht an die Tür einschlagen.
Aber der wichtige Fakt ist, den du vergessen hast, der europäische Omnibus wird
natürlich von Ursula von der Leyen gefahren.
Willst du da einsteigen? Traust du dich das?
Okay, gut. Ich glaube, wir haben das Bild für diese heutige Sendung.
Also, was ist ein Omnibus im EU-Sprech? Oder überhaupt,
man nennt in der Gesetzgebung Omnibusse etwas, wo du Kraut und Rüben zusammenmischt,
wo einfach Gesetze geändert werden, die eigentlich nicht sachlich miteinander verbunden sind.
Und du hast eigentlich fachfremde Themen und Materien vermischt in ein Gesetz.
Oft sind diese Omnibusse auch nicht wirklich relevante Änderungen,
sondern eher Streichungen von Gesetzen.
Man könnte es auch Drive-By-Shooting nennen. Und diese Omnibusse werden deswegen
natürlich auch oft sehr ohne Sachkenntnis verhandelt, sondern da hast du dann
halt 20, 30 Themen, die abgehandelt werden in einer Sache.
Und ja, es gibt auch so einen Omnibus für netzpolitische Themen,
der uns besonders viel Sorge bereitet.
Heute am 14. Oktober ist die Begutachtung dafür abgelaufen, der Call for Evidence.
Und der Grundnarrativ für dieses Gesetz ist, es gibt einen Grund,
wieso wir in Europa keine mächtigen Tech-Konzerne haben.
Und das ist diese ganze störende Digitalregulierung.
Nicht das fehlende Internet?
Nee.
Ach so.
Und die Universitäten, in die es reinregnet?
Auch nicht.
Es ist auch nicht irgendwie die fehlende Strategie oder die fehlenden Investitionen
oder dass wir irgendwie Vergabeprozesse haben, die Amerikaner bevorzugen.
Nein, nichts davon. Es ist wirklich die DSGVO und die anderen Gesetze.
Aber können wir bitte ganz kurz darüber reden, über welchen DSGVO-Artikel wir
da reden, der simplifiziert werden wird?
Das ist nämlich interessant, wenn man über Innovation spricht.
Ich kann leider die Artikelnummer nicht auswendig, aber es ist tatsächlich der
einzige Artikel, der sozusagen genauere Regeln an die Hand geben würde,
wie Unternehmen DSGVO umsetzen wollen.
Also sie sagen, die GSGVO ist eine Innovationsbremse, aber wir wollen den einzigen
Artikel streichen, der eigentlich Unternehmen vorgeben könnte,
wie sie das besser umsetzen können. Das ist ein bisschen ein Treppenwitz.
Das ist es. Dieses ganze Paket besteht aus einer Wunschliste von konservativen
Regierungen, was sie nicht gerne streichen würden von der Gesetzgebung der letzten zehn Jahre.
Beste Zusammenfassung ist, es ist halt die Wunschliste der Europäischen Volkspartei.
Alle Bürgerrechtsschranken, die man gerne loswerden würde, finden sich hier.
Also es geht um den gesamten Data-Archie, also DSGVO, Data Act, Data Governance Act.
Es geht um den AI-Act, den will man sowieso auf Sankt Nimmerlein verschieben,
der soll in nächster Zeit gar nicht in Kraft treten und auch die Regeln,
ab wann etwas eine Hochrisiko-KI-Anwendung ist oder vielleicht sogar ganz verboten
ist, die will man auch runterschrauben.
Thema NIS2, Cyber-Sicherheitsgesetzgebung, will man die Grenzen für Meldepflichten
runterschrauben, also wenn ein Unternehmen gehackt wird,
dann muss es das vielleicht dann nicht mehr melden an die Zuständigen stellen,
was auch heißt, dass diese ganzen Sicherheitsinzidenzen unbekannt und unentdeckt bleiben.
Wäre ja gar kein Problem für Deutschland, weil uns wurde ja das zweite Mal jetzt
von Expertinnen gesagt, dass der Umsetzungsvorschlag von Deutschland zu NIS
2 nicht funktionieren wird. Wir hängen da eh noch hinterher.
Ja, Österreich auch. Aber ihr habt wenigstens in Zeiten Vorschläge auf den Weg
gebracht. Von letztem Jahr ist gescheitert und seitdem ist es still im Wald.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob still im Wald besser ist als Quatsch vorschlagen.
Also ja, Deutschland ist transparent. Bei uns ist der Quatsch-Vorschlag noch
nicht öffentlich geworden.
Und ja zuletzt auch EIDAS findet sich in diesem Omnibus und da darf ich mich
selber gleich revidieren, weil ich aber vorher gesagt habe, wir haben dieses
tolle Projekt, wo wir dann diese Ökosystemtransparenz aufzeigen wollen,
weil Europa da ja diese Registrierungspflicht hat.
Und genau diese Registrierungspflicht will man wieder abschaffen,
noch bevor das Gesetz in Kraft ist.
Und das ist so strunzdumm. Du müsstest jetzt eigentlich Klarheit haben in der
Umsetzung, kommunizieren, was da kommt, sodass die Bevölkerung vorbereitet ist.
So, folgendes wird sich ändern und auf diese Schutzschranken könnt ihr euch
auch verlassen, aber mitnichten,
es gibt jetzt ein fettes Damokgeschwert, das wahrscheinlich über die nächsten
ein bis drei Jahre bedeutet, dass man einfach eine riesige Richtsumsicherheit hat.
Ja, also dieses Paket wurde jetzt konsultiert und der Gesetzesvorschlag wird erwartet so für den 19.
November, also ein bisschen mehr als ein Monat.
Das ist auch nicht viel Zeit, um die eingelangten Einreichungen zu analysieren.
Stand heute Nachmittag waren das 260 Einreichungen, die sich da mit den Vorschlägen auseinandersetzen.
Ja und ich finde es auch wichtig an der Stelle zu sagen, dass das alles ein
bisschen nahe an dem ist, was sich Donald Trump von Europa wünschen würde.
Wir haben ja die Sprechblasen aus Brüssel gehört, als der Orange King gepoltert
hat und seine Forderungen aufgestellt hat. Man würde hier nicht einknicken.
Also dieser Omnibus sieht schon sehr nach dem aus, was sich Donald Trump wünschen
würde. Da ist jetzt zwar der DMA und der DSA noch nicht drinnen.
Ich glaube auch, das sind Gesetze, die sehr wichtig sind und wo man sich vielleicht
auch aus einer europäischen Perspektive nicht drüber traut, die zur Disposition zu stellen.
Aber eine Datenschutzgrundverordnung aufzumachen und zu reformieren,
das ist natürlich das, was wir aus den USA seit vielen Jahren hören.
Und wenn wir nicht jetzt wachsam sind und Europa sich da vielleicht nochmal
anders besinnt, dann haben wir einen großen Abwehrkampf vor uns in den nächsten Jahren.
Also ich glaube, diese Gesetzgebungsperiode auf EU-Ebene, die nächsten vier,
fünf Jahre, stehen unter dem Zeichen, Schlimmeres abzuwenden und überhaupt nur
zu verteidigen, was wir schon haben.
Da geht es nicht mehr um Zukunft gestalten, da geht es eigentlich nur darum,
nicht den Boden unter den Füßen weggezogen zu bekommen.
Aber was befürchtest du denn jetzt konkret, was über diesen Omnibus so als erstes fallen könnte?
Also wir haben den Call for Evidence, der ist relativ vage, aber wenn man in
den Pfeils drinnen ist, weiß man in welche Richtung, was sie da andeuten.
Das ist immer vage. Diese Calls for Evidence sind meistens so vier,
fünf Seiten, aber man sieht schon an der Debatte und an den Wortmeldungen der
Kommission, worauf sie hinaus wollen.
Und es gibt Einreichungen von uns, von IDRE, von vielen Institutionen zu diesem Fall.
Und was da angesprochen ist, ist auf jeden Fall AI Act, NIST 2,
der gesamte Data Archie, also DSGVO und Konsorten und eben EIDAS.
Das ist, glaube ich, noch wichtig zu betonen. Also eigentlich legen sie die
Axt an alles an, was wir momentan nutzen können, um digitale Grundrechte zu verteidigen.
Und das finale Gesetz kommt dann eben später dieses oder Anfang nächstes Jahr.
Das liegt komplett in der Hand der Kommission. Wann und was genau,
das wissen wir dann, wenn wir die ersten Leaks bekommen.
Und ja, dann wird es halt ein großer Kampf werden.
Und, müssen wir jetzt schon irgendwas tun?
Also die Konsultation ist mit heute vorbei, insofern offizielle Wege sich da
einzubringen gibt es jetzt leider nicht mehr.
Ich glaube das Wichtigste ist überhaupt mal Bewusstsein zu schaffen,
wie irrsinnig es ist jetzt unsere Grundrechte aus dem Fenster zu schmeißen.
Das ist nicht, was uns wettbewerbsfähig macht. Das ist nicht der Standortvorteil
von Europa, dass wir das, was Vertrauen schafft, ja abschaffen.
Was soll uns sonst irgendwie abgrenzen von den USA oder China oder anderen Märkten?
Aber ja, ich glaube, darüber reden hilft und es in die Debatte bringen.
Das wollte ich hier auch tun.
Und der Aufruf, ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, da ist die Kampagnen-Webseite,
Dort ist der Petitionstext, den ihr unterschreiben könnt.
Da sind wir noch ein bisschen zu früh.
Sobald die Kommission hier konkreter wird mit ihren Plänen, kann man diese Instrumente diskutieren.
Das ist vielleicht in einer der Folgensendungen etwas, das ich als Update bringen kann.
Ja, wann denkst du, wann es sich so konkretisiert? Also ist das jetzt etwas,
was unmittelbar bevorsteht oder vergeht da jetzt üblicherweise nochmal eine Menge Zeit?
Ich glaube, dass das schnell geht. Also das kolportierte Datum,
das ist nicht offiziell, aber das ist, was man in Brüssel hört, ist der 19.
November, zu dem der Gesetzesvorschlag bereits vorgestellt werden sollte. Das wäre sehr schnell.
Ja, in der Tat, weil es ja bald geht.
Also binnen eines Monats.
Ungefähr, ja.
Okay, aber es gibt in dem Sinne noch keinen Text, den man kennt.
Nein, nein. Jetzt sind wir in der Konsultation.
Du befürchtest nur Schlimmstes.
Ja, ich kenne meine Pappen, aber ich sehe den Text und die Sorge teilen auch viele.
Okay, also kommt das Thema, der Omnibus fährt hier noch ein paar Mal durch, die Sendung sozusagen.
Genau, das heißt, das müssen wir machen, Stoppschilder abstellen.
Haarkarten kontrollieren, ist doch klar.
Jeder, der keine hat.
Fliegt raus. Internetführerschein in der Eudi-Wallet. Das wäre eigentlich eh,
kein Internet mehr, wenn du nicht den Führerschein in der Eudi-Wallet hast.
Diesen tollen, den man machen konnte vor zwei Jahren.
Hast du den erst vor zwei Jahren gemacht?
Nein, den muss ich...
Der ist doch Pflicht für CCC-SprecherInnen.
Wieso hast du den nicht? Kannst du den nicht nachweisen?
Internetfett mit Bits, nicht mit Führerschein. Nee, er hat einen Ehrenführerschein.
Einen Ehrenführerschein. Ach so, naja, also ich weiß ja nicht bei deinem Baujahr.
Also ich hab das ja sozusagen alles, ich bin ja vom Alter her geschützt.
In meinem Alter brauchte man noch keinen Internetführerschein.
Du genießt Bestandsschutz.
Naja, wir sind ja nativ da reingeboren worden.
Aber der Omnibus geht ja auch an den Bestandsschutz, also musst du vorsichtig sein.
Vielleicht kommen wir, vielleicht kommen wir. Ach so, die wollen mir meinen
Internetführerschein wegnehmen, dann toll.
Nee, aber guck mal, also jede einschneidende EU-Regulierung oder überhaupt Regulierung,
wenn man sagt, lass uns doch mal überlegen.
Autos so zu bauen, dass sie nicht mehr unseren Planeten ruinieren.
Dann sagt man, ja okay, aber lass uns Ausnahmen machen.
Umweltzone, ja Ausnahme, außer die Autos, die zu alt sind, dass sie das noch
erfüllen können. Die dürfen einfach wieder so rein.
Sonst geht das ja nicht. Und,
Gebäudemodernisierung oder so, ja außer Denkmalschutz. Weil dann kann man das nicht machen.
Das ist Luxus in der Klinierung dann.
Und im Internet könnte man ja dann auch quasi so Bestandsschutz,
so für die Meta-Ebene oder auch zum Beispiel für WhatsApp.
DSGVO, ja, aber WhatsApp hat Bestandsschutz oder Denkmalschutz,
irgendwie sowas, um jede Möglichkeit noch irgendwas durchzusetzen, halt zu unterwandern.
Mit genug Ausnahmeregeln.
Wer jetzt schon Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung macht, darf weiter.
Achso, ohne Hintertür, genau.
Das ist denkmalgeschützt hier. Ich mach hier denkmalgeschützte Quanten-Krypto.
Das machen wir schon dann so. Aber dann fangen die KI-Leute auch an zu argumentieren,
dass sie das ja auch schon in den 70ern gemacht haben und das deswegen immer noch dürfen.
Klar, da wird jedem was einfallen. Da wird jedem was einfallen.
Oh Mann. Lass uns schnell vorankommen hier im Thema. Die Sendung gleitet uns schon wieder.
Bestandsschutz, Tim.
Die Sendung hat Bestandsschutz.
Ich bin gerade sehr dankbar für das Lachen, weil ich muss gleich mit dem nächsten
schwierigen Thema weitermachen. Wir erinnern uns.
Nee, Moment. Eigentlich wollten wir noch irgendwo reinschieben,
dass Tim kurz Apple dafür verteidigt, dass sie diese Ice-Warn-App auslösen hat.
Oh, ja stimmt.
Ja, stimmt. Vielleicht noch was Lustiges.
Als kleiner Bonbon.
Also was ist passiert, Linus? Apple hat eine App aus dem App Store entfernt.
Google auch, aber bei Google ist das natürlich kritikwürdig.
Ich würde nur gerne kurz hören, warum es bei Apple völlig in Ordnung ist.
Welche App ist es denn?
Die Ice-One-App. Also in den USA ist es ja im Moment so, dass teilweise sich
nicht ausweisende militärartige,
aber auch teilweise irgendwie in keiner Form gekennzeichnete Menschen Hetzjagden auf Menschen machen,
die irgendwie nicht bestimmten,
Kriterien der äußeren Wahrnehmung genügen, im Zweifelsfall eine Hautfarbe haben,
die nicht dem Trumpschen Ideal entspricht also wenn du nicht orange bist du
schon mal eine Risikostufe hoch und ähm,
Man sieht ja jetzt, da gibt es immer diese Fokusbereiche, wo dann diese mitunter
militärisch wirkenden Gruppen durch Innenstädte gehen und irgendwelche mexikanisch
oder schwarz oder sonst wie auffälligen Personen jagen und von der Straße zerren.
Ja, wenn die nicht schnell genug mit ihrem Fahrrad wegfahren.
Genau, ohne Ausweise, ohne Dienstnummern.
Oder wie in Georgia in so eine Hyundai-Autofabrik reinmarschieren und die ganzen
Südkoreaner, die da arbeiten, hops nehmen.
Die sozusagen in Amerika Autos bauen.
Ja, vor allem die von Hyundai dahingeschickt wurden, damit irgendwie diese Fabrik
funktioniert, so nach ihren Standards.
Aber das geht halt irgendwie gar nicht, was irgendwie in Südkorea auch für nennenswert
Aufmerksamkeit gesorgt hat und das ist irgendwie nicht gut.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht ganz genau, wie das ausgeht, aber ich glaube,
es könnte auch darin resultieren, dass Hyundai einfach die Fabrik wieder platt
macht und sagt, wenn ihr uns hier nicht haben wollt, dann gehen wir halt.
Das heißt, für viele Leute, die in den USA wohnen, ist das jetzt,
die müssen nicht nur überlegen, wie ist das Wetter draußen, regnet es oder nicht,
sondern die müssen auch halt gucken, wo sind gerade die,
ja, diese Gruppen unterwegs, kann ich die umfahren,
wo ist Stau, regnet es und wo sind die Eisgruppen, die, wenn ich Pech habe,
mich von der Straße zerren oder und da gab es halt eine App, die das ermöglicht.
Kennst du Blitzer Pro? Das ist ja zum Beispiel auch. Also eigentlich stehst
du morgens auf, wie ist das Wetter, was muss ich anziehen? Wo ist Stau?
Wo sind Blitzer? Was braucht man noch so typisch,
Nachrichten gucken, wo schafft Donald Trump gerade wieder Frieden?
Das ist ja auch ein Risikobereich.
Und dann halt, wo snatchen mich Leute einfach von der Straße?
Und diese App gab es bei Google und bei Apple im App Store,
wo Leute die Sichtung dieser gewaltbereiten Horten auf einer Karte darstellen können,
auf das man im Interesse eines friedlichen Tages die Risikobereiche umfahren kann.
Und diese App wurde natürlich sofort aus den App-Source wieder rausgenommen also.
Die App heißt Eisblock,
ein.
Bisschen wie die Corona-Warn-App halt nur jetzt ein bisschen später und die
hat Apple gestrichen und Tim wollte kurz erklären, warum Apple das richtig gemacht hat,
eben, deswegen kann das ja ich hab das auch nur als kurzes Thema aber.
Das ist bestimmt nicht übereinzubringen mit dem Digital Services Act.
Ich erinnere mich noch, als wir über die Absetzung von Jimmy Kimmel geredet
haben hier im Podcast und dann habt ihr auch gemeint, ja, Disney-Abo kündigen
würde ja nichts bringen, hat aber was gebracht.
Konnte ich halt nicht machen, weil ich kein Disney-Abo habe.
Ich auch nicht, aber was macht man jetzt gegen Öffel?
Ja, ich kündige jetzt mein iCloud.
Ja, mach.
Ne, mal gucken, muss man ja gar nicht. Was...
So, soll ich mal erklären?
Nee, Tim hat schon den Beschwerdebrief an den anderen Tim geschrieben.
Das glaube ich nicht. Tim, erklär.
Ich werde einen Scheiß tun, hier irgendwas zu rechtfertigen.
Aber man kann ja mal drauf schauen, was da eigentlich so generell ist.
Also ich meine, dass Apps aus dem App Store genommen werden,
ist auf Staatsdruck, ist sozusagen nichts, was jetzt irgendwie alle drei Monate
stattfindet, sondern offensichtlich ist das irgendwie am laufenden Meter der Fall.
Also ich kenne jetzt die Zahlen nicht so ganz genau, aber was ich gehört habe,
ist, dass das sozusagen so in den Hunderten irgendwie täglich stattfindet und
dass es also permanent irgendwas gibt,
was ist, aber ich kann es jetzt gerade nicht im Detail belegen,
aber es ist so ein permanenter Prozess und teilweise basiert das dann halt auf,
also ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, wie das jetzt in den USA rechtlich abgesichert
ist, aber es ist natürlich offensichtlich,
dass jetzt die Trump-Regierung alles versucht, um irgendwie die ihnen so verhalten.
Hasstenlinken in irgendeiner Form in den Schwitzkasten zu nehmen.
Diese App, ich meine, es gab so einen ähnlichen Fall in Hongkong.
Da hatten wir so eine App, die halt auch die Demonstranten gewarnt hat, wo jetzt gerade,
regierungsnahe Truppen in irgendeiner Form die Polizei versucht,
irgendwelche Sperrungen zu machen oder Kontrollen durchzuführen.
Hat Apple auch gelöscht.
Das ist gemacht worden und das hat auch nicht nur Apple gemacht,
sondern es haben halt alle Smartphone-Anbieter sozusagen, also alle App-Stores gemacht.
Und ich glaube, das sieht bei Google auch nicht anders aus. Oder?
Und Hongkong, China hat gesagt, das ist der Navigationsdienst für Aufrührer, diese Hongkong-App.
Ja, genau, weil ja diese maskierten, bewaffneten und mit Schutzkleidung ausgestatteten
Ice-Agents sind ja auch sehr zerbrechliche Personen.
Die sind enorm fragil, die brechen sich am laufenden mit den Fingernägen ab.
Snowflakes.
Die Snowflakes, also die sind quasi mit Glasknochen ab Werk ausgestattet und
werden deswegen in diesen Combat geschickt und da muss man natürlich alles tun.
Ich meine das Argument ist halt so, ja diese App wird ja dazu benutzt,
hier staatliche, Gewalt werden sie wahrscheinlich nicht in der Formulierung
gehabt haben, aber so staatliche offizielle Tätigkeiten zu behindern.
Und es würde ja diese Agenten in irgendeiner Form gefährden.
Das ist sowieso die Argumentation der Trump-Regierung und das ist natürlich Quatsch und Unsinn.
Andererseits denke ich halt auch nicht, dass jetzt sagen wir mal an dieser App der Widerstand hängt.
Aber es ist natürlich wieder so ein Punkt, wo sich alle Geister daran scheiden,
wie man denn jetzt damit umgehen soll.
Was könnte denn jetzt passieren? Also die Regierung macht jetzt irgendwie Druck,
jetzt könnten sich natürlich die Firmen hinstellen und sagen,
nein, Widerstand bis zum Ende, wir tun das jetzt nicht.
Und das ist natürlich das andere Extrem, was man jetzt hier fordern könnte.
Aber ich meine, rufen uns mal bitte mal die Analogie vor Augen.
Also das ist eine Zensur von Informationsangeboten auf Zuruf.
Es gibt kein Gesetz, das so eine Eis-App blocken würde.
Wäre das eine Webseite und es würde einfach jemand aus der Regierung anrufen,
bei wem auch immer und sagen so, ey, das da weg bitte und am nächsten Tag ist
das so und du kannst dann nur Ex-Post eine Debatte darüber führen,
wie nicht okay das ist, aber es gibt keinen Rechtsweg.
Das ist schon sehr autoritär. Und dass wir das hier in einem komplett zentralisierten
App-Store-Modell, dass das passieren kann, war immer klar.
Und jetzt leben wir halt in so einer Welt. Es war immer so diese,
ja die Amerikaner, die haben doch Meinungsfreiheit als ersten Verfassungszusatz
und das ist da zu hoch gehalten, die würden doch nie und nimmer und wir können
denen schon irgendwie die Kontrolle über unsere Informationstechnik anvertrauen.
Die Hoffnung und der Glaube fällt uns gerade so richtig auf den Kopf.
Ja, aber ich denke, wenn es einen alternativen App Store in Amerika geben würde,
würde dieser alternative App Store das genauso um die Ohren geschlagen bekommen.
Also da glaube ich jetzt mal nicht.
Das glaube ich auch nicht.
Warum?
Weil das eben nicht.
Weil den keiner installiert hat.
Also unwahrscheinlich, weil er dezentral ist. Ja. Zweifelsfall.
Also ich glaube, dass es ein Hauptgrund, wieso Apple und Google hier so stark
Kuschen ist, deren Geschäftsinteresse, weil das ja große Unternehmen sind,
die besonders abhängig sind.
Und wenn jetzt F-Droid oder andere dezentrale Stores dienen,
würde ich viel eher den Mut und das Durchhaltevermögen zutrauen,
dass sie sich gegen solche Zensurgelüste zu wehrsetzen.
Naja, also da habe ich so ein bisschen meine Zweifel. Was meinst du jetzt genau
mit einem dezentralen Store?
Also die Regelung, die wir jetzt in Europa haben, ist ja jetzt nicht so komplett dezentral.
Also da müssen ja die Apps auch immer noch durch einen Security-Check durch.
Also es gibt sozusagen immer noch die Möglichkeit an einer Stelle,
also bei Apple, da quasi in irgendeiner Form eine Sperrung durchzusetzen.
Davon ausgehend, dass dasselbe Modell so auch in den USA wäre,
wäre der Hebel immer noch derselbe.
Also ich habe jetzt nochmal nachgeschaut, IceBlock scheint nicht im F-Trade-Store
zu sein, insofern ist es eine theoretische Frage, wo wir jetzt die Antwort nicht haben.
Aber ja, es gibt diesen Kill-Switch, den sich Apple ja auch bei den alternativen
App-Stores in Europa und ich glaube Südkorea gibt es den ja auch zugesteht.
Also die können immer noch eine App entfernen.
Das ist aber meines Wissens nicht passiert.
Ja, hier in dem Fall nicht, das stimmt. Aber es ist halt die Frage,
wie weit würden sie gehen?
Und die Architektur, die hier halt auf den Smartphones vorherrscht, hat diese Gefahr.
Und wir sehen das in den USA gerade wirklich sehr deutlich und auch wie schnell das gehen kann.
Ja, ich meine, was machen wir da jetzt draus? Also man kann das jetzt natürlich Apple vorwerfen.
Nein, aber das wäre doch zu kurz gedacht.
Ja, ich meine, vorwerfen muss man das natürlich jetzt der Trump-Regierung,
weil es ja vollkommen klar ist, dass wenn sie jetzt diese, wenn sie diesen Wunsch
ausdrücken, dass sie das halt mit so einem Mafia-Ton tun.
Or else, ne? Das ist ja sozusagen das Ding.
Hätte jetzt irgendwie eine beiden Regierungen dasselbe gewünscht,
dann wäre es wahrscheinlich auch anders gelaufen, weil wir wissen ja einfach, wie der Hase läuft.
Das Schlimme an der Stelle ist, und ich glaube, das ist eigentlich,
was mich erst recht wütend macht, da musste nicht mal irgendjemand dieses Or else sagen, oder?
Es gab nicht mal diese Nase rumpfende, man müsste doch hier mal was tun oder
sonst müssen wir was machen, so wie das damals von der FCC bezüglich Jimmy Kimmel kam.
Sondern das war der vorauseilende Gehorsam. Das ist so, ich bin zwar im Falle
von Apple einer der reichsten Konzerne der Welt, aber ich gehe dem Bulli lieber aus dem Weg.
Das ist feige und das ist nicht think different.
Und vor allen Dingen muss man auch sagen, dass Apple in der Vergangenheit ja
auch sehr stark Dinge gemacht hat und gesagt hat, nee, wir lassen euch nicht
an die Daten von diesem Gerät ran zum Beispiel.
Also es ist ja nicht so, dass Apple keine Eier in der Hose hat,
die es auch im Zweifelsfall irgendwie einsetzt.
Ja, die Debatte über die verschlüsselte Cloud und die ganze Frage des Zugriffs
auf die Geräte, die wird uns auch bald wieder begegnen.
Die ist ja schon wieder da in UK.
Ja, stimmt.
So eine Eisblock-App ist übrigens nicht so neu, diese Idee.
Ich erinnere mich an die Cop-Map vom Peng-Kollektiv, lange her.
Und die haben in ihrer Memoriam-Seite dazu auch die Titelseite des Berliner
Kurier. Die gefährlichste Karte Berlins.
Polizeihasser warnen Verbrecher. Auf einem neuen Internetportal kann jeder in
Echtzeit sehen, wo Berliner Polizisten im Einsatz sind. Auch Kriminelle.
Also auch die kriminellen Polizisten. Nein, nein, nee.
Nee, Kriminelle großgeschrieben. Achso.
Ja, also.
Also es ist übrigens auch nicht die einzige App, die mittlerweile in diesem Zuge gesperrt wurde.
Also es wurde auch noch eine App namens Eyes Up gesperrt, die halt so zur Archivierung
von entsprechenden Vergehen der Eisbehörde eingesetzt wurde.
Und wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal die letzte. Naja, ich meine,
wir haben es halt einfach hier mit einer,
faschistischen Powergrab zu tun in den USA und.
Und Apple stellt sich dem schon mal nicht entgegen.
Nö, auch alle anderen stellen sich dem nicht entgegen. Also ich meine,
welches Unternehmen stellt sich dem denn jetzt entgegen? Also habe ich jetzt noch von keinem gehört.
Land of the free.
Hört man irgendwie nichts mehr von den Unternehmen.
Naja, also mal ehrlich, das tut ja keiner.
Ja, ich erinnere mich noch so irgendwie vor der Trump-Wahl, als dann so irgendwie
die Leute in den USA wirklich noch so, yeah, we'll win this, believe in America.
Und das ist alles so lost, auch dieses Vertrauen, dass das nochmal besser wird
oder dass Politik überhaupt noch zu Lösungen beitragen kann in den USA,
die Schere zwischen dem, was dieses Land irgendwie mal propagiert hat und wie
es jetzt dasteht und wie es dazugeht, ist immer schreiend.
It's fucked up, man. It's fucked up.
Ja gut, jetzt sind wir genau in der richtigen Stimmung. So für das nächste Thema,
reden wir über die Vereinten Nationen.
Oh nein, jetzt konnte ich auch noch.
Brauche ich eigentlich den guten Nachrichtsjingel heute noch?
Nein, kannste löschen.
Wir erinnern uns an die UN-Cybercrime-Konvention, die in diesem Podcast schon
mal Thema war und auch bei Chaos Radio schon mal Thema war, als meine Kollegin
Tanja Facherthaler dort zu Gast war.
Die arbeitet nämlich an dem Thema und in ihrem Sinne verlautbare ich nur,
dass wie zu befürchten jetzt eben auch diese Konvention am 25. und 26.
Oktober offiziell in einer Signing Ceremony verabschiedet wird.
Das Ganze passiert in Hanoi, in Vietnam und dort wird sehr wahrscheinlich eben
die notwendige Anzahl von 40 Staaten zustande kommen, wahrscheinlich sehr viel mehr.
Also es gibt einige Staaten, die ganz klar sagen, yeah, das feiern wir.
Zuvor das natürlich Russland, die das Ganze ins Rollen gebracht haben,
aber auch China, Iran, auch Australien wird dem Ganzen zustimmen.
Genauso wie viele afrikanische und asiatische und lateinamerikanische Staaten
wie Peru, Kolumbien, Äquator.
Ja, aber auch die Europäische Union wird unterzeichnen und das ist wichtig,
weil würde die EU das nicht tun, könnten die EU-Mitgliedstaaten der Konvention nicht beitreten.
Und unter den Jubelpersern finden sich auch Österreich, Tschechien und Belgien.
Wieso ist das ein Problem? Weil diese Konvention, und das haben wir eh schon
x-mal ausgeführt, halt wirklich gefährliche Menschenrechtsstandards setzt und
es erlaubt auf Daten und Server und Computersysteme zuzugreifen,
Überwachungsmethoden zu etablieren, die man eigentlich eher ächten sollte und
das Ganze eben auch grenzüberschreitend.
Das heißt, es ist nicht mehr nur so, dass ein Staat sich da Straftatbestände
und Überwachungsmethoden ausdenkt,
sondern dass ein ganzer Katalog von beiden über alle Staaten drüber gestülpt
wird, die dieser Konvention beitreten und sie auch ratifizieren und damit in
ihr nationales Recht überführen.
Bei dieser Signing Ceremony in Hanoi werden nicht die Staatschef da sein.
Das ist schon mal ein gutes Zeichen. Es ist eine Stufe drunter mit den Botschaftern
der jeweiligen Länder in Vietnam.
Aber Antonia Guterres, der UN-Generalsekretär, wird vor Ort sein.
Und diese Unterschriften haben eigentlich keine rechtliche Bindung,
außer halt, dass die Konvention als solche in Kraft tritt. Aber die sind schon
ein starkes politisches Signal.
Und es gibt drei Länder, von denen wir wissen, dass sie nicht unterzeichnet
werden. Die sollten auch positiv genannt werden.
Schweiz, Finnland und Mexiko.
Die stellen sich dagegen, die teilen unsere Menschenrechtsbedenken.
Also denen sei gedankt an dieser Stelle.
Wie Deutschland abstimmen wird, ist noch unklar.
Das ist es ja immer.
Das ist der Standard.
Überwachungsgesetz, unklar. Ja, wissen wir jetzt nicht. Müssen wir nochmal generell drüber nachdenken.
Aber ich hatte da Hoffnung. Also Deutschland war in den Verhandlungen sehr hilfreich.
Aber jetzt zuletzt haben sie sich nicht in die Karten schauen lassen.
Und es ist auch unklar, wie Schweden, Kanada oder Costa Rica abstimmen.
Und jetzt wird es spannend.
Auch die USA sind wieder ein Fragezeichen.
Dieser Vertrag wurde ja unter Regierung Biden ausgehandelt. Da waren die Amis noch dafür.
Und jetzt unter Trump ist das Ganze aber natürlich wieder was,
worüber neu nachgedacht wird.
Trump ist ja kein großer Fan von Multilateralismus und von internationaler Zusammenarbeit.
Und auch die Vereinten Nationen sind ihm eher ein Dorn im Auge.
Und wenn die USA diesem Vertrag nicht beitreten, dann könnte das eigentlich für uns gut sein.
Weil das bedeutet, dass dort, wo ein Großteil der Daten sind,
wo die Dienste bereitgestellt werden, das ist dann das Land,
wo du nicht darauf zugreifen kannst.
Also da haben wir Hoffnung auf eine gewisse Art und Weise.
Natürlich wird Russland das als Hauptargument verwenden. Das ist nämlich der
Grund für diese Konvention, weil die dann sagen, ja, das ist nur dieser amerikanische
Kolonialismus, die haben die Daten für sich und geben sie nicht her,
auch wenn sie von unserer Bevölkerung sind.
Aber wichtig ist, wenn Trump dem jetzt nicht zustimmt, das kann jede nachfolgende Regierung ändern.
Also man kann auch Jahrzehnte später noch so einer Konvention beitreten,
dass es gang und gäbe und wir werden auf jeden Fall weiter dranbleiben,
auch weil ein großer Teil von den Implementierungskonferenzen in Wien stattfinden wird.
Also wir sind dort weiter am Parkett und werden lobbyieren dafür,
dass auch jetzt in der Ausgestaltung der Überwachungsmethoden der polizeilichen
Zusammenarbeit das Ganze eben entlang von Menschenrechtsstandards passiert.
Und klar ist aber, welche Rolle wir als NGOs haben werden, auch darüber wird
gerade verhandelt, ob das Ganze eben so wie bisher mit einem Rederecht,
auch mit einem Fragerecht, ob wir schriftliche Einreichungen geben können oder
ob man uns da aus dem Raum sperrt, wie es in anderen Konventionen eigentlich üblich ist.
Man muss auch sagen, das war das erste Law Enforcement Treaty,
wo überhaupt Zivilgesellschaft mit am Tisch war.
Das war so eine der Konzessionen, die man Russland damals abgerungen hat.
Insofern ist es spannend, wie es da weitergeht und we keep you posted.
Alright, dann hast du gerade schon von Konferenzen gesprochen,
da gibt es auch bald wieder eine.
Das ist eine gute Nachricht.
Mal gucken, die gute Nachricht, dass sie stattfinden wird, hatten wir glaube ich schon.
Und zwar der Chaos Communication Congress, der gerade noch den CFP offen hat.
Und drei Viertel der hier Anwesenden sind auch in den Content-Teams.
Es gibt Einreichungen in den Tracks Art & Beauty, Hardware & Making,
Ethics, Society & Politics, Science und Security & Hacking.
Der CFP, das ist jetzt die wichtige Information, für einige eine gute Nachricht.
Für einige wird diese Nachricht am 25.
Oktober zur schlechten Nachricht, denn der CFP ist geöffnet bis zum 24.
Oktober 20.25, 23.59 Uhr.
Also am 25. Oktober ist schlecht. Davor ist gut.
Welche Zeitzone?
UTC.
UTC? Also hat man bis ein Uhr nachts Zeit hier. Eine Internet.
Ja, vorsichtig. Ich glaube, es gibt
da nochmal irgendwann so eine Uhrzeitumstellung. Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Na gut, aber UTC ist auf jeden Fall hinter uns.
Gut.
Es steht da auch, oder?
Du wolltest gerade Klarheit schaffen.
Ich habe einfach nur eine Nords-Diskussion gehabt.
Es gibt halt eine Zeit und die ist UTC. Da bist du jetzt... Ja, du bist voraus.
Die Zeit ist einfach... Die Notation ist eine schwierige Geschichte.
Sogar auf diesem Sprint-Event hat wieder irgend so ein Hirni es geschafft,
diese Event-Zeiten mit AM und PM anzuzeigen. Ich meine, hallo...
Nur weil es Englisch ist, oder
was? Sprunginnovation. Ja, also das ist ein Rücksprunginnovation ist das.
Zeitsprunginnovation.
Super. Sollte mal lieber an irgendwelchen Telefon stellen, mit denen man in
die Vergangenheit reisen kann oder in die Zukunft arbeiten.
Machen die ja, deswegen hat er ja auch eine Zeit aus der Vergangenheit angezeigt mit AM und PM.
Darf ich doch mal generell mal einen Rand nochmal kurz, weil das macht mich einfach wahnsinnig.
Reicht ein. Wenn ihr eine Veranstaltung habt, bitte verwendet nicht EM und PM,
das hat mit Internationalisierung nichts zu tun, das ist nicht international,
das ist Amerika verstehst du, jede normale,
Zivilisation benutzt selbstverständlich das 24 Stunden Zeitsystem und mit EM
und PM das hat einfach von dieser Erde getilgt zu werden, also bitte achtet da drauf.
Und dann würde ich gerne noch um ein weiteres bitten Datum ein Datum wird,
Datum in Dateinamen, kommen wir direkt zum Thema Dateinamen,
also Datum in Dateinamen Nein, gibt nur eine Jahr.
Monat, Tag Mit Dateinamen ist das so.
Ja Und was gehört auch nicht in einen Datei?
Emojis Tim, jetzt wird man nicht frech Das ist irgendwie so wie ich versuche
hier Basics Tim hat den ja auch.
Nur ehrenweise den Internetführerschein,
Bestandsschutz.
Bestandsschutz Was gehört nicht in einen Dateinamen?
Ich weiß jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht warum.
Leerzeichen.
Leerzeichen im Dateinamen. Was kommt als nächstes? Emoji oder was?
Aber wollen wir vielleicht nochmal auf den CFP zurückkommen?
Nein. Also wir haben jetzt so eine sinnlose Diskussion. Und dass wir uns auch
mal Raum geben. Ich mache das schon seit Jahrzehnten.
Mache ich selbstverständlich Leerzeichen. Ja, selbstverständlich.
Nein.
Aber das ist auch vor dem Suchen total kacke.
Was? Quatsch.
Das ist, weil du ein Weibcoder. irgendwie alles nur noch, überleg mal, wie...
Alle Strings escapen.
So eine Podcast-Sendung, ist einfach ein Fest der Liebe und der Harmonie.
Wie im Liebeausschuss.
Ein Fest der Liebe.
Wie war das jetzt nochmal mit dem Kongress?
24. Oktober, Einreichungsende.
Könnt ihr euch merken, ist zwei Monate vor dem anderen Fest.
Ja, aber vielleicht Ich wollte euch auch einfach merken, dass das in zehn Tagen
ist. Das klingt vielleicht ein bisschen dramatischer.
Und wenn ihr richtig nett seid, reicht ihr nicht erst kurz vor knapp ein.
Ja, bitte.
Also mir hat mal jemand gesagt, ich sag jetzt nicht wer, aber diejenige weiß es bestimmt.
Wer auch immer vor dem Tag des Einreichungsendes einreicht,
fällt unter Verdacht, Serientäter zu sein und wird von vornherein sowieso abgelehnt.
Was, wenn man es zu früh macht?
Ja, klar.
Das heißt, es kommen nur die durch, die zu spät einreichen?
Nee, aber das war eine Heuristik für jemand, der hat einen Google-Alert auf
CFP und eine fertige Einreichung, die überall gemacht wird.
Aber es gibt ja auch Streber, die ihre Bachelorarbeit eine Woche früher abgeben
und das sind auch die gleichen Menschen.
Die… Streberinnen in diesem Fall. Es gibt eine Streberin. Es gibt eine Streberin.
Die Uni hat doch auch sofort die Eis gerufen und hat gesagt, das stimmt was nicht.
Diese orientierungslose Frau, die ihre Bachelorarbeit eine Woche zu früh abgeht.
Ja, ja. Wer sowas macht, hat auch Emojis in der Teilnahme.
Okay, ich glaube, wir haben das jetzt geklärt.
Wir haben das Thema abschließend erörtert. Also einreichen am 24.
Oktober 2025, 23.59 UTC.
Wer zu früh oder zu spät einreicht, wird nicht mehr ernst genommen.
Das nennt man Fallhöhe.
Tim, das gibt doch eine gute Nachricht.
Ja genau, ich will eine gute Nachricht schicken.
Okay.
Österreich hat ein neues Grundrecht.
Man glaubt, es gab überhaupt schon eins.
Nee, die tauschen das.
Das heißt jetzt anders.
Behandle deine Grundrechte wie deine Unterhose.
Lass mich raten. Lass mich raten. Man darf jetzt Emojis in der Tat.
Genau, das machen wir die noch zu fleißen. Na aber gut, wenn ihr das Thema aufpasst,
also die österreichische Bundesverfassung ist ja mehr so die Ikea-Anleitung für die Republik.
Also wir haben nicht, also ich habe ja...
Ohne Worte oder was?
Fast. Aber ich habe ja wirklich Grundgesetzneid. Also die deutsche Verfassung...
Grundrechtsneid oder Grundgesetz auch?
Ja, also alles. Das ist the whole multi. Und bei uns war das halt wirklich,
die Bundesverfassung ist eine Bauanleitung, wie du diese Republik zusammensteckst.
Nichts von Werten, nichts von Rechten.
Aber wir haben die EU-Grundrechte-Charta im Verfassungsrang.
Das war schon mal ganz gut. Das hat uns uffel geholfen. Die EMRK haben wir auch.
Aber wir waren immer hinten nach. Vor allem bei diesen modernen Grundrechten
wie Informationsfreiheit.
Es hat jetzt gerade wirklich lange gedauert, die Kampagne dazu von den Kollegen
von Amtsgeheimnis und Forum Informationsfreiheit über zehn Jahre.
Ich glaube, seit 2013 haben die gekämpft. Und jetzt mit 1.
September 2025 gibt es zum ersten Mal ein Grundrecht auf Informationsfreiheit in Österreich.
Verrückt.
Also wir waren ein bisschen spät dran. Also ich glaube, wir sind die letzte
Demokratie Europas. Ich glaube, auf dem Papier gab es sogar in Belarus sowas.
Hinter uns war nur noch irgendwie der Vatikan.
Die sowas nicht brauchen. Aber wir haben es jetzt geschafft.
Wir haben auch natürlich, wie in Deutschland bekannt, fragdenstaat.at, gibt es.
Ist auch dieselbe Software, auch betrieben von unheimlich coolen Leuten,
die seit vielen Jahren an dem Thema dran sind und meine vollste Hochachtung
haben für den Einsatz für Informationsfreiheit. Selbstverantwortungsfreiheit.
Und wie bei jedem Grundrecht, es ist wie ein Muskel, das muss man auch verwenden, damit es was bringt.
Auch damit in der Verwaltung ein gewisses Umdenken passiert und die wirklich
die Infos rausgeben. Dafür braucht man Fragen.
Und wer auch immer in Österreich ist oder sich für Österreich interessiert,
nutzt dieses Grundrecht.
Man darf da ja auch Anfragen in anderen Ländern stellen. Ich mache das gerne
auch mal hin und wieder in Deutschland.
Und wenn ihr schon immer mal was wissen wolltet, fragt den Staat.at.
Nutzt die Chance und lasst eurer Neugier freien Lauf.
Es gibt ja genügend Kuriositäten, die es wert sind, erfragt zu werden.
Ich habe mich selber gerade erst ausgetobt.
Moment, die haben schon 3047 Anfragen.
Das sind bestimmt alle Spots, das sind genauso wie die E-Mails,
die an die CDU-Politik rausgehen.
Aber die durften bisher alle noch nicht beantwortet werden.
Weil wir hatten kein Grundrecht. Wir hatten ein Auskunftsgesetz,
aber das war halt eher so, du darfst fragen und wir dürfen dir antworten, aber nicht müssen.
Okay, weil die Plattform ist ja schon älter. Also die älteste Anfrage,
die ich jetzt finde, ist zwölf Jahre und acht Monate her.
Das ist die Anfrage zum Umsetzungsstand der Richtlinie 2011-24 EU.
An das ehemalige Bundesministerium für Gesundheit. Und das Ergebnis war,
äh, lalalala, gab eine Antwort. Sehr geehrter Herr Sasic, ein Link gekriegt.
Wurde ihm ein Link geschickt.
Genau, so das war das Maximum, was du dir erhoffen konntest,
unter der alten Rechtsgrundlage.
Jetzt gibt es wirklich ein Grundrecht. Jetzt kriegst du nicht nur eine Zusammenfassung
von dem, was deine Frage vielleicht meint, sondern du kriegst die Dokumente.
Du kriegst wirklich die Zahlen, die Fakten, die Studien,
die Excel-Tabellen und Und das ist wirklich neu, das ist ein großer Kulturwandel,
ist der Reich, alte Monarchie, da ist auch viel Unterwürfigkeit gegenüber der
Obrigkeit noch in den Knochen der Leute. Da hoffen wir natürlich was dran zu ändern.
Fragen haben wir da nicht so gerne in der Monarchie. Genau.
Weil du bist der Untertan, nicht der Souverän.
Wer ist daran jetzt schuld, dass es dieses Gesetz gibt?
Thomas.
Ich war da wirklich nur Supporting Actor. Das waren wirklich die Kollegen vom
Forum Informationsfreiheit, Markus Hambetner oder der Matthias und Josef Barth und andere Leute.
Die NGO, die das Ganze vorantreibt in Österreich, ist eine, mit der wir uns
auch schon mal im Büro geteilt haben.
Die machen coolen Scheiß. Also das, was Open Knowledge Foundation in Deutschland
ist, sind die für Österreich.
Und die, wieso jetzt gerade, ist eine gute Frage, die letzte Regierung,
also die von ÖVP und Grünen hat dieses Gesetz beschlossen.
Das ist auch nicht perfekt, aber es ist halt trotzdem mal ein großer Schritt
in die richtige Richtung.
Ich war damals auch im Ausschuss als Experte geladen und durfte meinen Senf abgeben.
Es war sicherlich ein langer Kampf, aber ganz ehrlich, als die Grünen in die
Regierung kamen, war das für sie auch so, die eine Sache, seit zehn Jahren wird
darüber geredet, entweder wir machen es jetzt oder es passiert nie.
Und dann hat man halt diesen Schritt gesetzt. Es ist auch ein Gesetz,
das auf Bundes- und Landesebene einheitlich den Informationszugang regelt.
Das heißt, man kann auch in den Bundesländern wie Tirol oder Vorarlberg,
die weit weg von Wien sind, Fragen stellen und auch bei Gemeinden.
Der Preis dafür ist, dass es eine sogenannte Ewigkeitsklausel hat.
Also dieses Gesetz bräuchte eine Verfassungsmehrheit, um geändert zu werden
und die Zustimmung aller neuen Landeshauptleute und Frauen.
Das bedeutet, es wird niemals passieren.
Also müssen Österreich neu gründen jetzt, um das Ding wieder loszuwerden?
Genau, ja.
Gut, das ist auf jeden Fall ein höherer Aufwand.
Ja, also maximal vielleicht so ein Anschluss oder sowas. Aber ja.
Aber es wäre auch eine Option. Aber Ikea. Österreich neu gründen.
Sagen wir so, wenn Bayern mitgehen würde und wir uns losspalten.
Wie, Österreich und Bayern zusammen?
Aber dann nur noch echte Wurst, ne? Nicht mehr hier so eine...
Du und deine veganen Wurst. Also ich finde das eigentlich gut, dass wir jetzt hier...
Vorsachliche Diskussionen haben.
Ja. Auf jeden Fall verlinken wir nochmal ein paar lustige Anfragen zu diesem Thema.
Und das ist glaube ich alles, was man dazu sagen sollte.
Okay. Dann war das jetzt auch alles, was wir dazu gesagt haben.
Jetzt wird nichts mehr dazu gesagt. Mit anderen Worten, Ende der Sendung.
Ich habe mich sehr gefreut, dass wir so jung nochmal zusammengekommen sind.
Ja, ich komme jetzt auch in eure Altersklasse.
Was?
Seit wann?
Du meinst, der Politbetrieb hat dich so sehr altern lassen, dass du jetzt schon hier nachkommst.
Wer seine Masterarbeit eine Woche zu früh abgibt, ist eh in einer ganz anderen Altersklasse.
Das ist so erwachsen. Das ist eklig.
Aber das wusstest du doch schon vorher, Linus, dass ich erwachsen bin.
Ohne Altersverifikation.
Das habe ich an deinem strengen Blick immer vermutet.
Ja gut, du musst öfter kommen. Ich finde das gut.
Sehr gerne.
Ich komme vielleicht auch öfter nach Berlin.
Na dann, also machen wir dann einfach zu zweit.
Ja genau.
Immer einen EU-Podcast.
Du gibst die Sendung einfach eine Woche vorher ab.
Aber vielleicht zum Abschluss, schreibt weiterhin euren CDU-Abgeordneten nette E-Mails.
In UTC.
Ohne Hemmojis.
Ohne Leerzeichen im WM-Datei. haben.
Kein AM-PM-Verbettung.
Denn das macht Ihnen Angst. Wollte ich eigentlich sagen.
Angst vor E-Mail. Ich habe auch lange noch Angst vor E-Mail.
So Leute. Schluss hier. Wir sagen Tschüss. Vielen Dank fürs Dabeisein, Thomas, Kalissi.
Und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war's. Bis bald.
Ciao, ciao.